Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich spreche in Mikrofone. Und jeden letzten Donnerstag im Monat tue ich das fürs Chaos Radio, das heute hier auf fritz.de stattfindet im Blue Moon. Und wo Leute vom Chaos Computer Club oder aus dem näheren oder weiteren Dunstkreis dazukommen, um eine beliebige Technik oder politische Diskussion, die mit Technik zu tun hat oder irgendetwas, was irgendwie mit dem Internet zu tun hat, hier näher zu präsentieren und zu erklären. Und wir möchten heute über ein Thema sprechen, das kann man auf zwei verschiedene Arten ankündigen. Und die eine ist, glaube ich, eher abstreckend, wenn man sagt, wir sprechen heute über die technischen und politischen Probleme des Glasfaserausbaus in Deutschland. Oder man kann sagen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr sitzt zu Hause vor allem im Internet und habt mir vielleicht schon mal gewünscht. Also wenn man Glück hat, dann hat man so ein 100 MBit und kann dann ganz viel runterladen, aber wenig hoch. Und das ist das Beste, was geht. Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir alle so richtig dickes Internet zu Hause haben und wie das funktionieren kann? Oder warum es vielleicht heute nicht funktioniert? Das bestrechen wir heute hier in diesem Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Und dazu sind wirklich viele, viele, viele Gäste ins Studio gekommen. Nämlich Johannes Lenz-Havlicek. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Vielleicht ins Mikrofon hineinsprechen. Das ist im Radio immer sehr wichtig. Außerdem Stefan Wahl. Und Filz. Und Mutaks. Da sind also vier Leute, die hier sind und die alle irgendwie mit diesem seltsamen Internet zu tun haben und uns in den nächsten zwei Stunden genau darüber auch aufklären, informieren und vielleicht auch ein bisschen diskutieren werden. Und ich, weil das wirklich viel sind, möchte ich vielleicht am Anfang, dass ich euch ein bisschen genauer vorstelle, warum ihr hier seid und was genau ihr mit diesem breitbandigen Internet zu tun habt, das möglicherweise bald bei uns überall zu Hause liegt. Fangen wir mal bei Mutaks an. Der eine oder andere Treuhörer hat ihn vielleicht schon mal gehört.
Ja hallo, ich bin der Mutaks und ich hab Internet.
Aber woher?
Zuhause tatsächlich aus einem Coax-Kabel über einen Kabelprovider und das Spannende ist aber, dass meine Eltern im Verlauf des letzten Jahres FTTH bekommen haben. Was das ist, erklären wir ja nachher noch. Das heißt, die haben dieses geile Glasfaserscheiß im Keller.
Und warum bist du heute hier?
Ich kann ein bisschen plaudern, was da passiert ist, was da nicht funktioniert, was das Spannende ist. Und ansonsten bin ich halt mal wieder im Chaosradio. Hallo. Ich hab dir was mitgebracht.
Glasfaser. Okay, das ist sehr gut. Darüber muss ich auch noch genauer sprechen. Warum das wichtig ist. Ich habe Glasfaser, endlich. Aber vorher will ich noch den Filz vorstellen. Hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo.
Du bist wer und warum heute hier?
Ich bin der Filz, wie du schon gesagt hast. Ich bin vom Inverdienst, so ein kleiner Provider, den es schon seit Ewigkeiten gibt. Und ich mach schon seit 1996, 1997 mein Internet quasi selber.
Du machst dein eigenes Internet?
Na ja, meinen eigenen Zugang. Das ist am Anfang aus der Not geboren. Das ist halt noch kein richtiger Internetprovider für die breite Öffentlichkeit gab. Ja, und inzwischen ist es einfach angenehm zu wissen, was man tut, was da technisch abgeht.
Na gut, werden wir mal genauer noch herausfinden. Stefan.
Ja, guten Abend.
Guten Abend. Wer bist du und warum bist du heute hier? Und was hast du mit breitbandigem Internet zu tun?
Fangen wir mit der letzten Frage an. Ich habe vor über 20 Jahren nach dem Studium das Glück gehabt, bei einem Stadtnetzbetreiber in die strategische Netzplanung einzusteigen. Und bin damals das erste Mal mit Glasfaser in Berührung gekommen und konnte damals schon Internetbandbreiten nutzen, von dem der Endanwender damals noch wahnsinnig geträumt hat. Das hat mich damals so fasziniert, dass ich die Branche auch nicht gewechselt habe und jetzt seit 20 Jahren im Geschäft bin und so ziemlich alles miterlebt habe, was da jetzt in den letzten Jahren passiert ist. Wir werden nachher, Mutags hat es ja schon erwähnt, ein paar Sachen da mal beschreiben, was IP-Adressen vielleicht angeht, was Glasfaser ist, was für Bandbreiten man zukünftig erwarten kann, wo wir heutzutage stehen und ich denke, da habe ich ein paar Beiträge, die sicher sehr interessant auch für den einen oder anderen sein können und vielleicht auch motivieren.
Das klingt vor allen Dingen auch so, als ob das Problem nicht so ganz aktuell ist, schon ein bisschen länger existiert. Bin ich auch sehr gespannt und dann ist noch Johannes da.
Ja hallo, ich bin ebenfalls seit über 20 Jahren in diesem Geschäft unterwegs und verfolge bis heute das Interesse, dass wir vor allem das Phänomen haben, dass die Datenmengen ständig wachsen, aber die Kapazitäten, mit denen die Datenmengen übertragen werden, nicht steigen. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass so eine Glasfaserausbau unabdingbar ist, gerade auch ein symmetrischer Ausbau natürlich. Und das ist mein Interesse hier heute Abend.
So, da sind schon ein paar Punkte gefallen, wo man gleich anknüpfen kann. Also das eine ist, das allererste ist, was du gerade gesagt hast, ist nicht genug. Ich hatte ja irgendwann, also mit dem Inseher, das ging ja so los, in der 1 Mbit, dann 2, dann 4, dann 8, dann 16, dann 32. Und jetzt ist man so bei 50 und 100 angekommen, was man so als Privatanwender sozusagen normalerweise meistens bekommen kann. Und ich dachte irgendwann so, das ist schon okay. Also ich kann damit jetzt gut arbeiten. Mir fällt jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie auf, dass es langsam ist. Also ja, wenn man hoch lädt, ist es halt weniger, dauert ein bisschen länger, aber meine Güte, das geht schon. Was glaubt ihr denn, also jetzt noch nicht mal, was es gibt, sondern was glaubt ihr denn, was man so perspektivisch in den nächsten Jahren zu Hause braucht? Also wo soll es denn hingehen, die Reise? Einfach mal eine Zahl sagen.
Es ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, was man für eine Bandbreite braucht. Natürlich so viel wie möglich. Das mal von vorne weg, weil der Zeitfaktor spielt eine große Rolle. Es gibt so Zahlen, die im Raum sind. Bei einer Voice-over-IP, wenn das Internet benutzt wird, um zu telefonieren, dann will man unter 200 Millisekunden Verzögerung haben. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man jetzt einen Film guckt, bei einem der Online-Video-Portale, will man auch nicht minutenlang warten, bis das vor oder zurückgescrollt wird. Man will den Film eigentlich möglichst schnell in seiner kleinen Setup-Box drin haben. Da ist nach oben keine Grenze. Wenn du mich jetzt festnageln wolltest, würde ich sagen, genau das. Ein Gigabit symmetrisch. Das ist eine schöne runde Zahl.
Das ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, falls euch diese Zahlen alles nicht sagen, das ist die Geschwindigkeit, die bei euch zu Hause möglicherweise da ist. Also zwischen Router und Computer ist vielleicht noch ein Netzwerkkabel und kein WLAN und da sozusagen, da ist so ein Gigabit. Könnte da durchgehen. Okay, gibt es da Widersprüche? Irgendwie will jemand mehr, weniger bieten?
Nein, Gigabit ist sehr nett. Wenn es weniger ist, geht das glaube ich auch schon ganz schön. Aber Hauptsache ist halt symmetrisch. Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel meine Fotos bei Rossmann entwickeln lassen möchte oder einem anderen Bilderdienstanbieter, den es da draußen gibt, möchte ich halt nicht die ganze Nacht warten, bis meine 30, 40 Bilder hochgeladen sind. Sondern ich möchte das Notebook abends auch ausmachen können und schlafen gehen können und nicht die ganze Nacht drödeln haben. Und dann kommen wir halt schnell da weg, dass es bei DSL halt wirklich lange dauert. Wenn du viele Fotos hast, die Qualität wird immer besser. Und wenn du spätestens anfängst, dass du irgendwelche Videos drehst oder streamen möchtest von zu Hause, brauchst du halt auch deine große Bandbreite. So zehn Megabit reichen da dann nicht mehr zurück ins Internet.
Na ja, das wollte ich gerade fragen. Also man hört das oft, also dieses symmetrisches Schlagwort, das wird uns heute Abend auch noch häufiger begeben, vermute ich. Und das wird zwar immer gefordert. Und ich habe aber auch das Gefühl, das ist eher eine politische Forderung als wirklich eine praktische Relevanz für, Achtung, alle.
Na, die praktische Relevanz kommt jetzt immer mehr, weil alle wollen irgendwie die Cloud benutzen. Das heißt, ich habe meine ganzen Dateien nicht mehr zu Hause, sondern ich möchte auch unterwegs drauf zugreifen. Spätestens, wenn ich dann mal unterwegs wirklich auf Bilder zugreifen möchte, auf Medien, auf irgendwie mein Fotoalbum und meiner Mutter irgendwie mein Kind zeigen möchte oder sowas. Und diese Bilder liegen dann bei mir zu Hause, dauert das ewig. Das heißt, da wäre ich wieder gezwungen, das zu irgendeinem Diensteanbieter im Internet hochzuladen, was wir eigentlich alle nicht mehr wollen, weil wir wollen ja Privatsphäre haben, wir wollen die Dienste selber betreiben, wir wollen nicht, dass das irgendwo in der Cloud liegt, wo andere drankommen.
Ach so, warte mal, du sagst also quasi, wenn der Anschluss in beide Richtungen sehr schnell wäre, dann wäre die Cloud unsere eigener Computer.
Genau, dann ist das nämlich mein eigener Computer, der bei mir zu Hause steht und ich kann von woanders problemlos darauf zugreifen.
Da möchte ich aber wieder fragen, also das ist ja schön und gut, wenn du das machst, weil du die Ahnung hast, wie du dein Computer einstellen sollst, aber ist das wirklich ein Ziel, was man verfolgen will?
Na aktuell passiert das halt nicht, weil die Bandbreiten das nicht hergeben, deswegen gibt es keine Produkte und keine Dienste und keine Software und deswegen wird das nicht genutzt, deswegen wird es auch niemand anbieten.
Ich würde mal einschieben, das ist ja eigentlich durchaus schon so, dass es im Konsumerbereich Festplatten zum Beispiel gibt, die mit Remote-Access-Fähigkeiten verkauft werden. Das wird ja den Konsumenten heute schon im Media Markt und anderen solchen Orten feilgeboten, dass man diese Geräte nutzen kann, kaufen kann. Und insofern glaube ich nicht, dass das utopisch ist, dass wir von diesen Home-Cloud-Anwendungen sprechen. Und wenn man ein bisschen weiterguckt auf Sachen wie Virtual-Reality-Anwendungen, die auch sehr datenhungrig sind oder auch was Pragmatisches wie irgendwelche Gesundheitsmonitoring-Geschichten, die zeitkritisch sind, da ist natürlich der Upload auch ein wichtiger Faktor, dass der eine vernünftige Geschwindigkeit hat.
Das heißt also, ihr sagt, es gibt schon sehr viel technische Equipment, was wir gerade schon haben, oder Entwicklung, die vor der Haustür steht, die momentan dadurch beschnitten wird, dass unser Internetanschluss zu Hause nicht schnell genug ist.
Das Internet war eigentlich immer ein Netzwerk, was gleiche mit gleichen verbunden hat. Eigentlich immer so, dass sie symmetrisch in beide Richtungen die gleichen Bandbreiten existiert haben.
Also immer so ist sozusagen schon historisch betrachtet eine Weile her.
Ja, historisch 25 Jahre her vielleicht.
Also alle, die heute live zuhören, kennen es wahrscheinlich nicht anders.
Ja, also wir haben damals das Internet gebaut, voll symmetrisch. Wir wollten eigentlich, dass, egal von wo die Daten kommen, sie immer mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit in die eine wie in die andere Richtung geflossen sind. Daraus haben sich viele Dienste entwickelt über die Zeit. Am Anfang war es ja nur ein Austauschnetzwerk gewesen für Wissenschaftler. Und heutzutage wird auch sehr viel das eigene private Leben darüber transportiert. Da entstehen Unmengen-Applikationen, Unmengen-Möglichkeiten, die man damit machen kann. Aber Voraussetzung dafür ist, dass wir den nächsten Schritt, das ist meine persönliche Meinung, damit wir den nächsten Schritt machen können, ist, dass wir auch das Netz, dass wir mehr ins Netz auch reinbringen können. Und nicht nur konsumieren, sondern dass wir auch von uns aus Sachen in das Netz packen können. Cloud wurde angesprochen, Video wurde angesprochen, Fotografie, das kennen wir alle. Und das Internet hat uns über die letzten Jahre immer wieder überrascht. Und wenn man die Autobahn, also diese Datenautobahn öffnet, um mal einen weit strapazierten Begriff zu benutzen und der Mutter schüttelt sich gerade.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das war der erste Facepalm der Sendung. Und der Mutter kann gleich mal erklären, warum das sozusagen ein schlimmer Begriff ist, aber...
Der Datenautobahn ist ein schöner Begriff, den versteht man sehr leicht und kann sich das gut vorstellen. Wenn man die Autobahn einfach aufmacht, dann sind vielleicht wenig Autos erst mal drauf, wenig Services. Aber mit der Zeit wird das immer voller werden. Und wir drosseln in die eine Richtung im Moment das Internet, den Zugang zum Internet.
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, ob man das jetzt als Bild verwenden können, um tatsächlich diese Symmetrie nochmal ganz anschaulich zu erklären. Das Internet ist eine Röhre, ist ja auch so ein schönes Bild, was für Hände vor Gesichten gesorgt hat. Aber vielleicht könnt ihr euch das wirklich so vorstellen. Quasi eine Autobahn in der einen Richtung ist vierspurig und voller Lamborghinis und rückt zu Pferdekutschen auf einem schmalen, ausgetrampelten Pfad.
Du kannst es dir angucken. In Hamburg haben sie Straßen, die sie je nach Tageszeit mehrspurig in die eine oder andere Richtung machen. Genauso nach Berlin hier rein, die Heerstraße. Da werden die Spuren je nach Bedarf vergrößert und verkleinert. Was halt damit zusammenhängt, dass man nicht genug Platz hat.
Aber es ist ein gutes Bild. Warum hast du jetzt gerade den Kopf so geschüttelt bei Datenautobahn?
Ich hab den Kopf geschüttelt, weil Datenautobahn, hat Stefan ja schon gesagt, ein sehr strapazierter Begriff ist. Das sagen wir die anderen. Genau, das sagen meistens Leute, die von dem Thema keine Ahnung haben, um irgendwelche völlig abstrusen Vergleiche zu bringen, die dann gar nicht funktionieren. Also ein Beispiel ist halt Herr Oettinger, der sich da immer sehr, sehr um Kopf und Kragen redet und dann davon spricht, dass die selbstfahrenden Autos an der Grenze anhalten müssen, weil sie in ein Funkloch kommen. Und da ist dann der Schritt zur Datenautobahn halt sehr schnell.
Also aber heute die Leute wissen, wovon sie reden, wenn sie Datenautobahn sagen.
Hier schon.
Jetzt haben wir also zwei Sachen schon geklärt. Nämlich das eine ist, wir wollen mehr und das andere ist, wir wollen es symmetrisch und das sozusagen, und das mehr hat sich in den letzten Jahren sozusagen automatisch entwickelt. Das symmetrische ist tatsächlich was Neues. Und jetzt werden wir heute im Verlauf der Sendung ganz viel über Glasfaser reden. Aber um das sozusagen vorneweg noch mal zu sagen, es ist schon so, das eigentliche Ziel ist, man will symmetrisches, dickes Internet in jedem Haushalt. Und Glasfaser, wir reden jetzt gerade darüber, weil das die gängigste Technologie ist, die billigste, oder warum steht das jetzt sozusagen ganz weit vorne?
Na, es ist vor allem eine Technologie, die im Gegensatz zu vielem anderen zukunftssicher ist. Wenn wir jetzt sowieso Sachen neu verlegen müssen, macht es eigentlich keinen Sinn, da weiterhin so Klingeldraht in den Boden zu verbuddeln. Sondern da wollen wir eine Technologie haben, die zukunftssicher ist und das ist die Glasfaser. Weil ich im Prinzip einfach nur eine, naja, eine Röhre habe, durch die Licht durchgeht. Und wenn ich an den beiden Enden die Technik austausche, kann ich beliebige rande Lichtsignale dadurch senden. Das heißt, ich muss nicht das Kabel austauschen, um andere Dienste darauf zu machen.
Warte mal, fange ich jetzt schon damit an. Also ich habe hier so ein Glasfaser, das ist halt so ein dünnes, oranges, zweierdriges Ding, da sind zwei Stecker dran. Ist das jetzt sozusagen pro dieser Ader ist das ein Lichtsignal? Also die eine Ader gibt einen Lichtstrahl?
In dem, was du in der Hand hast, da ja. Man könnte dann auch noch mit verschiedenen Lichtfarben darauf arbeiten. Aber es ist pro Richtung ein Kabel quasi oder eine Ader. Und pro Richtung, pro Datenrichtung ist das ein.
Jetzt sagst du aber zukunftssicher, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen aber vier Kabel vergrabe, kann ich da nicht mehr durchbringen? Natürlich.
Kannst du. Und in diesen schönen Glasfasern, die wir da ins Haus oder in die Wohnung oder in den Keller oder an den Bürgerstädt legen, siehst du ja auch meistens mehr als eine Faser drin.
Okay, also das ist nicht unendlich zukunftssicher, aber absehbar zukunftssicher?
Man muss immer unterscheiden, die Netzebene. Also was du jetzt in der Hand hältst, das ist so ein klassisches Anschlusskabel für ein Endgerät, bei jemandem zu Hause zum Beispiel, oder wenn man wo zwei Glasfahne miteinander verbinden möchte. Die Kabel, die im Boden verlegt werden, die haben meistens 144 von diesen Fasern. Das Kabel ist ungefähr daumendick, was da verlegt wird. Und da kann man 144 oder 288 Leitungen draufpacken, einzelne, wie Mutags so schön gesagt habe, einzelne Lichtsignale drauf übertragen. Und an jedem Ende kann theoretisch ein Haushalt sein oder ein Haus. Und was man darauf übertragen kann im Stadtbereich und das definieren die Telekommunikationsunternehmen als Entfernung unter 15 Kilometer, kannst du mit wenig technisch Aufwand, mit sehr preiswerter Technik bis zu 10 Gigabit auf einer Faser übertragen. Und ein bisschen Mathematik, 144 Fasern mal 10. Und man kann sich schon vorstellen, was dabei auskommt.
Aber trotzdem sagen, also juristisch sozusagen ist es nicht unendlich erweiterbar, sondern aber es ist sozusagen das, was wir jetzt brauchen. Und wahrscheinlich auch das, was in zehn Jahren noch genügt sein kann.
Alles, was wir hier technisch haben, ist nicht unendlich erweiterbar.
Ja, aber das muss man ja auch sozusagen mal festhalten. So, wir reden heute sozusagen viel über Glasfaser und machen jetzt aber noch mal einen Schritt zurück, weil wenn man sagen, wenn es um Glasfaser geht, heißt es immer so, ja, aber überall ist Kupfer. Das ist sozusagen anscheinend so der Gegenspieler, also der, ähm, fällt kein gutes Bild ein. Dick und doof gehören dann zusammen. Also Kupfer. Warum Kupfer? Warum liegt überall Kupfer und was sozusagen? Wie geht das Internet durch das Kupfer und warum kommt da nicht mehr als 100 M mit raus?
Naja, es fing halt damals alles mit der Telegrafie an. Aber ich glaube, so weit wollen wir nicht ausholen. Du hast halt angefangen, irgendwann zwei Drahtleitungen in die Häuser zu legen, in die Wohnung, um darüber Telefonie zu machen. Das war halt für analoges Telefon gedacht. Und dann saß man eben an einigen Stellen dann da dran, dass man sagte, jetzt haben wir dieses Kabel, das in jede Wohnung geht, jetzt wollen wir da Internet drüber machen. Da wurde da ein Modem angeschlossen. Das waren irgendwie 56 Kilobit, die darüber ging, maximal.
Am Ende waren es 56, am Anfang hatten wir 300, 0, 3.
Also sehr wenig.
So.
Dann kam dann irgendwann an den Punkt, naja, wenn man das jetzt nicht analog mit einem Modem überträgt, also über Töne und Frequenzen, dann könnte man das ja digital übertragen auf höheren Frequenzen, die im nicht mehr hörbaren Bereich sind. Dann kommen wir irgendwann zu DSL.
Also das Modem war, egal wie schnell es war, immer noch eine hörbare Tonfolge, die da passiert ist.
Genau, und diese ganzen Technologien sind immer der Versuch gewesen, wie man mit dem vorhandenen Klingeldraht, der in die Wohnung geht, noch irgendwie was Sinnvolles machen kann, ohne ihn rausreißen zu müssen. Und das zieht sich halt bis heute durch. Das heißt, wir haben eine Infrastruktur, die ist irgendwann mal von der Deutschen Bundespost aufgebaut worden, ist dann verschenkt worden an eine private Firma, im Wesentlichen gegen einen symbolischen Preis. Und die versuchen damit heute noch, Internet zu machen mit den Leuten zu Hause, ohne dass sie jetzt in jede Wohnung neue Kabel legen müssen. Was ja einerseits verständlich ist, was uns aber mittlerweile halt wirklich, wirklich hart ausbläst.
Aber warum sozusagen, du hast ja gerade gesagt, aus einer so einer Glasfaserkabel kann 10 Gigabit rausfallen. Warum nicht aus Kupfer?
Das hängt damit zusammen, dass Kupfer, wir wollen nicht Nachrichtenübertragungsvorlesungen hier halten, möglichst einfach halten.
Das stimmt.
Man kann über das Kabel nur einen bestimmten Frequenzbereich übertragen, auf der Entfernung. Sagen wir mal auf 600, 800 Meter, weiß jeder, das analoge Telefon hat 3 Kilohertz Bandbreite gehabt. Jetzt muss ich diese 3 Kilohertz, dieses Signal reinpressen, oder ich muss halt das Signal, das Analogsignal weglassen, muss digital übertragen. ISDN hat damals 144 Kilobit übertragen auf 2 Draht Kupfer, bis 1, 6, 2 Kilometer korrigiert mich. Ich hab die genaue Zahl jetzt nicht im Kopf. Die Schwierigkeit ist, dass die Höhe die Bandbreite ist, die da übertragen wird. Umso stärker ist die Dämpfung des Kupferkabels. Das heißt, umso schlechter ist das Signal, was hinten am Ende rauskommt. Und umso schwieriger wird es technisch, immer mehr Bandbreite aus dem Signal rauszuziehen.
Ich muss mal kurz sagen, also ein digitales Signal durch ein Kupferdraht zu schlagen, heißt das quasi Strom an, Strom aus?
Genau, Strom an, Strom aus.
Und wenn ich sozusagen ein breitbandiges, also viel Signal übertragen will, heißt das, ich mach den Strom möglichst schnell an und aus. Richtig. Und je schneller ich das mache, desto kürzer wird der Weg, wo das sinnvoll geht, über einem Kupferkabel.
Genau.
Das merkst du ja auch daran, dass vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch daran, wenn man einen DSL-Anschluss sich da irgendwie klickt, muss man immer angeben, wo man wohnt. Und je weiter man von der Vermittlungsstelle weg wohnt, umso geringer wird die Geschwindigkeit, die man da kaufen kann. Und dann ruft dann da ein Techniker an und sagt, jetzt müssen wir die Leitung durchmessen. Und nun, ihre Dämpfung sieht aber ganz schlecht aus, gucken sie doch mal in der Fritzbox. Je weiter man weg ist, umso schlechter ist das Nutzzignal, was noch hinten rauskommt. Weil man viel mehr Rauschen drin hat. Man hat zum Teil sogenanntes Übersprechen von den anderen Leitungen, die mit verlegt wurden, das heißt die Nachbarn stören. Das heißt, sobald der erste Nachbar auch eine DSL-Leitung bekommt und der zweite oder der dritte wird dann die eigene immer schlechter. Irgendwann bricht das zusammen. Und diese Probleme hat man auch bei dem, was wir jetzt als Vectoring haben.
Was ist das?
Vectoring versucht jetzt über andere Technik, auch wieder über die Kupferkabel eben bis zu 100 Megabit zu übertragen.
Du hast aber jetzt einen 100-Meter-Sprung gemacht.
Ich hab jetzt mehr als 100 Meter gemacht. Das Prinzip ist dasselbe. Da wird ja argumentiert, dass man beim Vectoring dafür sorgen muss, dass die alle in der gleichen Frequenz schwingen im Prinzip, damit die sich nicht gegenseitig stören. Und deswegen darf dann nur noch die Telekom in diesem Providerkabelverzweiger sein, in der Straße. Und alle anderen müssen sich bei der Telekom einkaufen, um dann von da aus in die Wohnung zu kommen.
Also quasi, man hat sozusagen einen großen Kasten in der Straßenecke. Da kommt, wie auch immer, können wir später auch darüber reden, kommt breitbandiges Internet hin. Das wird verteilt in der Straße.
Genau, das haben wir vor ein paar Sendungen ja auch schon mal.
Und weil die sagen, und dann gibt es viele Kupferkabel und die stören sich, wenn es verschiedene Anbieter sind, weil die dann nicht genau synchronisieren können, die Schirmung zwischen Kabel und deswegen...
Das Wichtigste hat aber dabei unterschlagen, es wird nicht mehr von den sogenannten Hauptverteilern, davon gibt es in Berlin 140 Stück, wo das alte Telefon im Prinzip dieses Kabel da geendet hat, in die Wohnung transportiert. Das kann dann auch mehrere Kilometer weit weg sein, sondern das wird jetzt, wie du gesagt hast, auf der Straße in unserem grauen Schrank. Da kommt ein Glasfaserkabel an mit hohem bandbreitigen Internet. Und dann gehen da 300 Meter maximal, vielleicht 400 Meter Kupfer bei dir in die Wohnung direkt rein. Und wenn du Glück hast, hast du den richtigen Querschnitt von dem Kupferkabel und dann kann man da drauf Signale bis 18 MHz, 20 MHz übertragen. Und dann hat man VDSL und dann hat man auf einmal die 100 MBit und die 40 MBit dann im Ablink, die man heute, wenn man seine Fritzbox aufmacht und man hat VDSL sehr wunderbar, sich grafisch anzeigen lassen kann. Man sieht das ja wunderbar, die Kurven da drauf. Jeder, der das hat, sollte es mal wirklich ausprobieren, wenn er es noch nicht gemacht hat. Das Problem nun bei der Sache ist, man kann nicht mehr als 18 MHz, 20 MHz Unfall machen. Diese Bandbreite ist begrenzt, weil dann kommt man in den Bereich.
Das sind diese 100 MBit.
Es ist Kurzwellenband. Es ist das Kurzwellenband.
Nicht noch jetzt Radiowellen mit reinbringen. Also man kann über Kupfer nicht mehr als 100 MBit.
Man kann noch ein bisschen mehr rausquetschen und vor die Grenze wird sicher bei 200, 300 MBit liegen. Dabei aber natürlich mit kürzerer Distanz und mit immer mehr Problemen das Signal noch so zu transportieren, als es nicht andere Dienste stört.
Also im Labor geht da deutlich mehr. Im Labor kann man wirklich mehr machen, aber in der Straße geht es nicht.
Und man darf nicht vergessen, diese Kupferkabel wurden zum größten Teil vor 50, 60 Jahren verlegt. Da hat noch nie jemand, erstens gab es das Internet noch nicht und zweitens hat noch nie jemand im Traum dran gedacht, solche hohen Datenraten irgendwo jemals überhaupt zu übertragen.
Okay, gut. Ich fasse jetzt mal die erste halbe Stunde zusammen. Wir wollen mehr Internet, wir wollen Internet symmetrisch, also zu sagen, dass der Upload genauso schnell geht wie der Download. Und wir wollen das für alle Haushalte und wir wollen möglicherweise in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft noch mehr Internet. Und Kupfer kann das nicht. Aber liegt überall. Gut, dann spielen wir jetzt eine kleine Musik und klären danach, warum das so ist und warum es sich anscheinend nicht ändert. Die Musik kommt heute von Difference. Es ist ein Creative Commons Musikalbum von Keegan Whiten. Der erste Song ist Don't Fake Your Love for Broccoli.
Neulich haben Mickey Chance ihr Record-Release-Konzert gespielt. Direkt beim Fritz-Studio in Kreuzberg im Musik und Frieden. Und alles aufgenommen. Wollt ihr mal hören? Könnt ihr. Das exklusive Record-Release-Konzert von Mickey Chance. Um 19 Uhr im Radio. Und danach noch eine Woche im Stream auf Fritz.D. Das Record-Release-Konzert von Mickey Chance. Live für Musik und Frieden. Haben wir neulich aufgenommen?
Der Bundestag hat den Gesetzentwurf für mehr Lohngleichheit zwischen Frauen und Männern beschlossen. Nach der neuen Regelung müssen Arbeitnehmer in Betrieben mit mehr als 200 Beschäftigten über die Bezahlung von Kollegen mit vergleichbaren Aufgaben informiert werden. Der Bundestag hat außerdem einem Gesetzentwurf zum automatisierten Fahren auf deutschen Straßen zugestimmt. Künftig dürfen damit Computer in Autos die Steuerung übernehmen. Der Fahrer muss aber jederzeit eingreifen können. Hunderte Menschen in Südbrandenburg müssen nicht für die Braunkohletagebau umziehen. Die Pläne zum Ausbau des Tagebaus in der Lausitz werden deutlich gekürzt. Das gab der Energiekonzern LEAG am Abend bekannt. Demnach wird der Tagebau Jenschwalde nicht weitergeführt, weil das dazugehörige 40 Jahre alte Kraftwerk technisch nicht mehr zeitgemäß sei. Damit bleiben drei Dörfer für die insgesamt 900 Einwohner erhalten. Ob jedoch der Tagebau Welt zu Süd noch erweitert wird, will die LEAG bis 2020 entscheiden. Eltern haften unter Umständen dafür, wenn ihre Kinder im Internet illegale Musiktauschbörsen nutzen. Das hat der Bundesgerichtshof entschieden. In dem Prozess ging es um ein volljähriges Kind, das über das FamilienwLAN Urheberrechtsverletzungen begangen hatte. Der Vater wollte keinen Schadenersatz zahlen und erklärte, dass nicht er, sondern eines seiner Kinder verantwortlich war. Welches wollte er aber nicht sagen. Der BGH entschied nun, dass in diesem Fall die Eltern haften und zahlen müssen. Russlands Präsident Putin hat bestritten, dass Russland sich im vergangenen Jahr in die US-Präsidentenwahl eingemischt hat. Kontakte, die russische Diplomaten in den USA unterhalten hätten, gehörten zu deren routinemäßiger Arbeit. Putin betonte gleichzeitig, dass seine Regierung bereit sei, die Beziehungen zu den USA wieder zu normalisieren. In den USA untersuchen das FBI und mehrere Kongressausschüsse, ob Russland den Wahlkampf beeinflusst hat. Verkehr. Na, eigentlich kommt erst mal, na ja, dann machen wir halt auf dieses schöne Bett. Hallo Autofahrer, auch noch das Wetter. Berlin haben wir Müggelheimgrad 13 Grad, in Rhein-Nikendorf 15, Karlo 9 Grad, Falkensee 13, Eberswalde und Folien 14 Grad. Heute Nacht meist trocken bei 10 bis 6 Grad. Morgen geht's dann Richtung Oder noch mit ein paar Wolken los. Später wird es dann sonnig und warm mit 22 bis 25 Grad. Jetzt zum Verkehr. Es gibt ein paar Vollsperrungen, nämlich auf der A100 Stadtring Richtung Neukölln zwischen Jakob Kaiserplatz und Hohenzollerndamm bis morgen ca. 5 Uhr. Auf der A111 Stadtautobahn Richtung Dreig Charlottenburg zwischen Heckerdamm und dem Dreig Charlottenburg auch bis 5 Uhr. Und auch auf der A115 Avus statt einwärts. Die ist im Dreigfunkturm. Da ist die Überleitung zur A100 Richtung Wilmersdorf gesperrt, ebenfalls bis um 5 Uhr. Ansonsten Rolls, da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz für die Hosentasche wollt, mit Livestream, Studio Message, Podcasts und jede Menge mehr, dann holt euch doch die Fritz-App. Kostenlos und werbefrei in eurem App oder Play Store.
Und ihr hört das Chaosradio im Blue Moon, das nicht das Chaosradio im Blue Moon wäre, wenn nicht seltsame Dinge geschehen würden. Zum Beispiel die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Mo und vorgetragen von Martin Schneider.
Amerikanische Provider dürfen Kundendaten verhökern. In den USA ist das Internet Providern erlaubt, die Aktivitäten ihrer User auszuwerten und zu verkaufen. Im Dezember wären Datenschutzvorschriften in Kraft getreten, die den Anschlussinhabern ein Opt-in-Recht verschafft hätten. Doch sowohl US-Senat als auch Unterhaus stimmten in den letzten Tagen für die Aufhebung der Regelungen. Die Unterzeichnung der Aufhebung durch den US-Präsident Trump gilt nur noch als Formsache. Damit entfällt auch die Verpflichtung, betroffenen Kunden über Hacks und andere Datenschutzverletzungen zu informieren. IT-Mittelstand fordert Digitalministerium. Der IT-Mittelstand in Deutschland verlangt die Einrichtung eines Digitalministeriums. Der Präsident des Bundesverbandes, IT-Mittelstand Grüni, sagte auf einer Messe, die netzpolitischen Entscheidungskompetenzen seien derzeit auf zu viele Ministerien verteilt. Die Folgen seien ein hoher Koordinationsaufwand, langsame Entscheidungen und Streit um die Zuständigkeiten. Deutschland drohe, international abgehängt zu werden. Expertenkritik an Datenschutzreform. In einer Anhörung im Bundestag zu der Reform, mit dem die Bundesregierung das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz an die neuen EU-Vorgaben anpassen will, wurde heftige Kritik von Datenschützern und Verbraucherschützern geäußert. Vor allem die geplanten Einschränkungen der betroffenen Rechte seien hoch problematisch. Die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte Voshoff sah erheblichen Nachbesserungsbedarf für die eingeschränkten Ansprüche von Bürgern, Einblick in über sie gespeicherte Daten zu erhalten, sowie diese korrigieren oder löschen zu lassen.
Die NerdNews im Chaosradio im Blumenohren, geschrieben von Mo, vorgetragen von Martin Schneider. Vielen Dank. Das Chaosradio im Blue Moon beschäftigt sich heute auf Fritz damit, warum das Internet bei uns zu Hause eigentlich so verdammt langsam ist. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde geklärt. Das liegt unter anderem daran, dass wir mit Kupfer unser Internet bekommen, also zumindest die meisten von uns. Und dass sich das nicht ändert oder warum sich das nicht ändert und was für Alternativen gibt, das wollen wir jetzt besprechen. Und da begrüße ich ganz recht herzlich zurück in dieser Sendung. Den Mutax, den Filz, den Stefan und den Johannes. Hallo. So, ihr habt uns in der letzten halben Stunde schön erklärt, warum wir mehr Internet brauchen und wollen. Und dass es hoch genauso schnell sein soll wie runter. Und dass das Kupfer, was derzeit bei uns durch Kupferkabel gebracht wird, dass das technisch einfach nicht dazu in der Lage ist, das schneller zu machen als, na ja, so 100 MBit, vielleicht noch ein bisschen, aber viel mehr passiert da nicht mehr. Und wir haben auch schon kurz übersprochen, dass Glasfaser eine Alternative ist, weil da sehr viele Daten durchpassen und das auch relativ zukunftssicher ist momentan. Das heißt, erste Frage an euch, der Weg jetzt mehr Internet nach Hause zu kriegen, wäre also überall Straßen aufreißen, Glasfaser rein, Kupfer raus, mehr Internet zu Hause?
Okay.
Können wir aufhören, oder? Ja, man könnte vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz… Bevor wir darüber reden, warum das nicht passiert, was natürlich noch von großem Interesse ist, würde ich jetzt hier noch ein bisschen mehr darüber reden wollen, wie denn so dieses Glasfaser Internet zu Hause aussieht. Also Mutak hat zum Beispiel ganz am Ende gesagt, es gibt FTTH, das heißt Fiber to the Home, also Glasfaser bis zu mir nach Hause. Es gibt aber auch FTTB und FTTC und noch viele andere verschiedene Sachen. Also gibt es sozusagen jetzt irgendwie eigentlich einen technischen Standard, Glasfaser Internet nach Hause zu bringen, oder gibt es da auch schon wieder 3000 verschiedene Sachen, wo Leute sich die Kopfweine schlagen, was jetzt die beste Art ist?
Es gibt mindestens zehn.
Warum?
Weil es schön ist, eigene Standards zu haben. Nein, tatsächlich hast du ganz verschiedene Probleme und Ausbausituationen, die du vorfindest, die du irgendwie umsetzen möchtest. Du hast Einfamilienhäuser, du hast Mietshäuser, du hast irgendwelche Städte, du hast das platt Land. Und da brauchst du immer unterschiedliche Lösungen, um möglicherweise auch mit vorhandenen Glasfasern, die im Boden liegen, was zu machen. Und dann kommst du auf ganz verschiedene Lösungen.
Warte, warte, warte. Da fällt mir was ein. Darüber wollte ich tatsächlich noch sprechen. Das fällt mir jetzt erst gerade wieder ein. Ihr beschäftigt euch seit Jahren schon mit Glasfasertechniken und findet, das ist das Geilste von der Welt. Die einzige Berührung, die ich mit Glasfaser jemals gemacht habe als normal-sharp-user, ist folgendes. Ich ziehe um in Friedrichshain, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Und da möchte ich sozusagen breitbeiniges Internet haben. Und da wird mir gesagt, ja, das tut mir aber leid. Du wohnst in der Glasfaserwüste.
Das ist in Mitte immer noch so.
Da gibt es kein breitbeiniges Internet. Jetzt habt ihr mir gerade in der ersten halben Stunde lang und breit erklärt, dass Glasfaser das allerschürfste von der Welt ist und Internet bis zum Get-No in mein Haus bringt. Und wie passt das zusammen?
Das ist eigentlich historisch bedingt. Wer die Wendezeit mitgemacht hat, hat mitbekommen, dass er, wenn er in Kreuzberg ein Büro aufgemacht hat, während der Wendezeit, kurz nach der Wende, er praktisch keine Telefonanschlüsse bekommen hat. Die Kapazitäten, die zwischen Ost und West existiert haben, waren so eingeschränkt, dass praktisch alles, was an Kupfer und Glas dagewesen ist, für die Verbindung zwischen Ost und West in Berlin benutzt worden ist. Und anscheinend scheint es da noch ein ziemliches Backlog zu geben, was noch nicht aufgearbeitet worden ist. Man hat dann versucht, mit Alternativtechnologien dann nachher die Telefonanschlüsse auch in diese Bezirke reinzubringen. Da sind aber nachher die Baugruppen, die Module, die man dafür braucht, um Internet zu machen, nicht verfügbar gewesen.
Diese Alternativtechnologien ist quasi, man hat Glasfaserkabel genommen, um Telefonie zu machen.
Das muss man sich so vorstellen wie eine Telefonanlage. Da kommt ein Glasfaserkabel an in eine graue Kiste. In diese graue Kiste dahin fallen 30 Telefonanschlüsse raus. Natürlich fallen nur Telefonanschlüsse raus und keine Internetanschlüsse.
Wait. Ihr habt mir vorhin gerade erklärt, wenn ich irgendwo in ein Glasfaserkabel lege, habe ich nie mehr Sorgen, weil ich kann an die Enden einfach andere Technik stöpseln.
Jetzt könnte man natürlich die Frage stellen, wie gehört denn eigentlich das Glasfaserkabel und wie innovativ dieses Unternehmen ist.
Das ist ein sehr schöner Insiderwitz wahrscheinlich, aber ich verstehe ihn nicht.
Na ja, das Kabel, was da im Boden liegt, gehört alles der Bundespost, äh, Entschuldigung, Telekom. Und die versuchen natürlich da ihre Technik, solange sie können, auszureizen für ihre Anbindungsfälle und das ist halt die Telefonie und haben wenig Interesse daran, jetzt diese gesamten Kabelverzweiger und Endpunkte von dem Opalnetz aus zu tauschen, weil sie also so auch ihr gesamtes Netz umbauen müssten. Und da haben sie jetzt gleich den Schritt gemacht, dass sie jetzt komplett auf IP-Telefonie gehen und im Prinzip die Umsetzung an der Straßenecke machen und nicht mehr in ihren Verteilersturm.
Ich verstehe es aber noch nicht. Also es gäbe dieses Glasfasernetz, das wurde dazu benutzt, um mehr Telefonanschlüsse zu ermöglichen. Und an der Stelle, wo das lag, gab es dann kein Kupferkabel mehr.
Genau.
Oder gab es sowieso nie Kupferkabel?
Ja oder viel zu wenig.
Okay oder viel zu wenig. So und dann hat die Telekom oder Ex-Bundespost gesagt, okay wir wollen da aber erstmal unser Telefon machen, aber das muss doch irgendwann sozusagen Quatsch gewesen sein. Also es gab doch einen Zeitraum, wo das Telefonsagen unwichtiger wurde, aber das Internet sehr viel wichtiger wurde, wo man auch als Telekom hätte sagen können, okay das kostet vielleicht ein bisschen Geld, aber dafür gibt es breitbeiniges Internet und wir sind die Vorreiter.
Ja und dann gibt es irgendwie zwölf kleine Stadtviertel, kleine Ecken, in denen die Leute sagen, da haben sie jetzt Glasfaser in ein Pilotprojekt gelegt und da müssten wir uns jetzt überlegen, wie bauen wir das aus und wir haben wie viele Millionen Kunden und wie viele Leute sind davon betroffen und dafür müssen wir jetzt extra eine neue Technik fahren und dann hat man es halt nicht gemacht.
Okay gut, jetzt weiß ich endlich, was die Glasfaserwüste ist. Gehen wir also zurück zu dem, was Glasfaser dann doch kann. Jetzt habt ihr schon vorhin gesagt, es gibt sozusagen verschiedene Verwendungen, aber von dem, was sie mir am Anfang erklärt hat, nämlich man legt einfach ein dickes Glasfaserkabel rein, wo sozusagen verschieden viele Einzelleitungen rausfallen, verstehe ich noch nicht ganz sozusagen, was dann der Unterschied ist, außer wie dick das Kabel ist, was ich irgendwo hinlege. Ich habe gerade gefragt, wie viele verschiedene Arten der Datenübertragung per Glasfaser gibt es? Die Antwort war mindestens zehn, weil es gibt verschiedene Anwendungsszenarien. Ich verstehe das aber nicht, weil ich würde ja denken, ich lege halt sozusagen so viele Glasfaserfasern dahin, wie ich Anschlüsse brauche. Und dann hat sich die Sache, vielleicht irgendwie 20 mehr, weil man weiß ja nie, und dann hat sich die Sache erledigt. Also was sind dann die unterschiedlichen Angebote?
Man muss ganz stark trennen. Man hat einen Übergabepunkt. Der Übergabepunkt, der kann zum Beispiel so ein grauer Kasten an der Straße sein, wo nachher VDSL rausfällt. Es kann aber auch im Gebäude sein, dass da ein Übergabepunkt ist. Und dann wird mit irgendeiner Technologie das Internet in die Wohnung gebracht, die Telefonie. Oder man kann auch mit einer Technologie dieses Glasfaserkabel verlängern in die Wohnung. Und es gibt die Möglichkeit, der Mutter hat das angesprochen, man stelle sich vor, dass man kann die Farben des Regenbogens in einem Glasfaserkabel übertragen. Und jeder Mieter kriegt eine Farbe von dem Regenbogen. Und am anderen Ende von dem Glasfaserkabel mach ich das Signal, vereinzel ich das wieder. Das heißt, ich hole wieder die einzelnen Farben dabei raus. Und damit kann ich auf einen Glasfaserkabel mehrere Kunden übertragen. Was jetzt im Grunde die Quintessenz daraus ist, es gibt nicht diese eine Lösung. Wie er jetzt schon gesagt hat, es gibt mindestens zehn verschiedene Varianten, die hängen davon ab, wie das Gebäude gebaut. Komme ich mit der Glasfaser bis in die Wohnung rein, liegt da schon ein Kabel? Darf ich überhaupt im Pflur einen Kabelkanal ziehen? Oder sagt die Wohnungsbaugesellschaft oder der Vermieter, nee, das ist nicht der Fall, das wollen wir nicht. Nicht in jedem Haus kann man Glasfaserkabel an die Außenfassade nageln, weil schon die Dämmung da draufgebracht worden ist. Alles Fälle bei mir zum Beispiel zu Hause könnte ich niemals ein Glasfaserkabel bekommen, weil sie im Treppenhaus das nie installieren werden. Und das, was früher mein Telefonkabel in die Wohnung, das kam über die Hausfassade. Und vor zwei Jahren ist das Haus gedämmt worden. Das ist jetzt alles schön unterputzt. Die werden garantiert nicht erlauben, dass sie jetzt auf diesen schönen glatten Fassade noch ein Glasfaserkabel rauf nageln.
Also okay, also wir können schon mal festlegen, ein Nachteil von Glasfaser ist, also wir haben das schon verschiedentlich jetzt erwähnt, aber man kann es vielleicht noch mal deutlich sagen, ein Nachteil ist, bevor wir Glasfaser in der eigenen Wohnung haben, ist, das muss komplett verlegt werden. Und es gibt, ich würde jetzt so denken, okay, da liegt da schon ein Kupferkabel, dann scheinert man das draußen ab und dann knüppert man das Glasfaserkabel dran und zieht das Kupferkabel oben raus und dann schlängelt das Glasfaser. Nein, so geht das nicht. Man muss es wirklich die Wand aufmachen.
Aus der Erfahrung des Praktikums als Elektriker vor meinem Studium kann ich sagen, dass die Berliner altbauten. Also wenn man da mal so einen Kanal findet, wo man das machen kann, das funktioniert vielleicht bei 30 Prozent der Wohnungen. Aber man will es ja für 100 Prozent der Wohnungen erreichen. Also so eine generelle Lösung gibt es ja nicht. Und jede individuelle Lösung, die da gesucht wird, kostet halt Geld. Und die kostet halt mehr Geld. Die großen Telekommunikationskonzerne, die wir in Deutschland haben, leben davon, dass sie standardisierte Produkte anbieten. Das heißt, sie haben Portfolio von fünf oder sechs Standard-Technologien, die sie benutzen. Und wenn man da nicht reinfällt in dieses Raster, dann ist man halt ausgesperrt. Und dann muss man sich halt einen Alternativanbieter suchen, der aber, weil er nicht die Masse der Kunden hat, meist deutlich teurer ist.
Darüber werden wir später noch reden. Es geht erst mal noch um die technischen Zugänglichmachbarkeit der Glasfaser. Wir müssen den Band auf jeden Fall aufreißen.
Montags? Da merkst du auch genau, warum die Telekom gerade dieses Vectoring anbietet. Sie verlängern im Prinzip die Glasfaser so lange, wie sie können, nämlich bis zum Bürgersteig, wo sie jetzt diese großen neuen Kästen in Berlin überall aufbauen und können von da aus weiterhin die vorderen Kupferkabel nehmen und müssen eben nicht Wände aufstemmen oder Kabel neu legen.
Darüber wollte ich ja später erst reden. Hab ich doch gerade schon mal gesagt. Was ich jetzt wissen wollte ist, wenn es jetzt das Glasfaser gibt, also auch in der Wohnung, ist das dann so, und dann hab ich dann irgendwie damit Internet, ist das dann so toll oder bringt das noch andere Sachen nach? So was wie zum Beispiel, ich brauch dann einen Router, der verbraucht 15 Kilowattstunden, weil die Umrechnung so hart ist. Ich, bei einem normalen Telefon hab ich, wenn ich eine Kupferleitung lieber hab, kann ich selbst mit Stromausfall glaube ich noch telefonieren. Also wenn man jetzt Glasfaser wirklich hat, gibt es dann nur Vorteile oder muss man da so sagen, ich sag mal diplomatisch, muss man da Sachen bedenken?
Wie immer, es gibt kein kostenloses Essen, da ist nur free lunch. Es hat schon Nachteile. Also der eine Nachteil ist halt das Thema Stromausfall. Wenn ich einen Stromausfall habe, über eine Kupferkabel konnte ich Strom fürs Telefon liefern, kann ich über die Glasfaser nicht mehr. Andererseits, alle Leute, die jetzt auf einen Voice-over-IP-Internetanschluss umgestellt wurden, die haben dasselbe Problem auch trotz Kupferkabeln.
Also das ist zwar ein technisch valides Argument, aber zunehmend ein historisches, weil über Kupferkabel auch die Telefonie mittlerweile...
Es wird immer historischer und hysterischer. Bei einem Kabel-Fernsehen- Anschluss über den Internetmacher habe ich das selbe Problem. Ich habe ein Kabelmodem, ich habe einen Router, die sind bei Stromausfall weg. Bei einem Deck-Telefon habe ich das Problem, wenn die Wasserstation keinen Strom mehr hat, kann ich noch so viel Nullstrom aus der Telefonleitung bekommen, es wird nicht funktionieren. Das ging bei ISDN, das hatte dafür einen Standard. Da kam Strom von der Vermittlungsstelle, der für ein Telefon gereicht hat. Bei manchen gab es einen Schalter, als man sagte, dieses Telefon ist das Nottelefon, alle anderen sind dann aus. Und beim analogen Telefon ging das, wo halt wirklich nur das Telefon direkt an dieser Kupferade angeschlossen war.
Immerhin wird es jetzt mit der Glasfaser vielleicht wieder ein bisschen besser, da wir jetzt die Glasfaser vermutlich vom Haus oder möglicherweise von meiner eigenen Wohnung bis in die Vermittlungsstelle haben. Das heißt, die Vermittlungsstelle hat vermutlich Notstrom. Und ich kann mir vielleicht eine kleine USB hinstellen, damit ich dann auch noch bei Stromausfall telefonieren kann.
Okay, mir fällt gerade noch vielleicht eine dumme Frage. Aber ich sehe ja, das ist hier ein Kabel. Das ist auch ein gewickeltes Kabel, was ihr mir mitgebracht habt. Aber frage mich trotzdem, ist das so?
Ah, er knickt es.
Das ist genau das, was ich gerade fragen wollte. Also Kupferkabel kann man ja irgendwie um ein Rohr wickeln, dann ist alles gut. Wenn man das verlegt muss, dann muss man da vielleicht irgendwie, man darf es halt nicht knicken, keine spitzen Winkel.
Genau, du darfst keine spitzen Winkel machen, die sind allerdings mittlerweile relativ robust. Das geht so weit, ich habe das ja am Anfang der Sendung kurz erzählt, meine Eltern haben das bekommen. Dadurch kommt man von Stadtwerken so eine Packung zugeschickt, muss vorher sagen, wie weit man von im Haus von der Anschlussdose weg ist. Und dann heißt es, naja, hier ist so eine Schablone drin, so weit dürfen sie es knicken. Das kann Elektriker machen, sie können es aber auch selber machen. Solange man da jetzt nicht wirklich brutal dran reißt oder es wirklich knickt, passiert da relativ wenig mittlerweile. Das ist machbar. Man sollte es halt nicht lose rumfliegen haben und auch nicht mit dem Bürostuhl drüber fahren.
Das Grundproblem, was du hast mit dem Kabel, ist nicht mal die Verlegetechnik. Das kann man relativ leicht, wie du im Montag schon sagte, mit einer Leere machen, mit einem Stück Pappe, wo man den Biegeradiusbehalt einhält. Die Schwierigkeit ist, dass man das Glasfaserkabel als Faser rausbekommt, als kleines, haardünnes kleines Faserchen, was in die Wohnung reinkommt. Und da muss ja irgendwo so ein Stecker rangemacht werden. Und bei Kupfer ist es ziemlich einfach. Schraubenzieher, eine Klemme oder diese LSA-Klemmleisten, da wird mit einem Auflegewerkzeug das einfach reingequetscht. Das Auflegewerkzeug kostet professionell vielleicht 15 Euro. Das jeder Elektriker versteht. Er haut einmal drauf, das Kabel ist drin in der Halterung und funktioniert. Bei Glas brauche ich wiederum ein sogenanntes Splice-Gerät. Ich muss das Glas im Prinzip an diesen Endanschluss ran schweißen. Also ich verflüssige das Glas so ein bisschen und drücke es dann zusammen. Das klingt, es ist wow, es ist in der Zwischenzeit sogar vollautomatisch möglich, aber die Geräte, die man dafür braucht, die liegen dann schon bei 5000, 10.000 Euro, wenn man da professionelle Technik einsetzt.
Das heißt, wenn das Klingeldraht abreißt, dann knüpfer ich das Ende ab.
Richtig.
Und sozusagen steckst du mal rein, wenn die Glasfaser bricht, brauche ich einen Typen, der sich irgendwann mal 5000 Euro ein Gerät gekauft hat und natürlich auch einen entsprechenden Stundenlohn haben will.
Das ist so dieses Grundproblem, dass die Werkzeugausstattung und auch das Know-how höher sein muss, um Glasfaser zu machen. Auch einer der Gründe, warum das so ein bisschen schleppend ist. Und gerade in Miethäusern schwierig. Ich meine, in Einfamilienhäusern ist es einfacher. Da zieht man eine Straße ein Kabel lang, das hat 144 Häuser, sind rechts 144 Kabel, sind in dem Glasfaserbündel drin. Und jedes Haus kriegt eine Faser ins Haus. Unten hat man so einen Übergabepunkt, da haut man das rein. Und es bleißt einmal. In einem Miethaus in Berlin, in der Straße, in derselben Entfernung, da sind im Haus 6, 2 Dutzend Mietparteien. Ich müsste so und so viele Anschlüsse da reinlegen. Allein die Kosten dafür, selbst wenn man die sehr günstig einkauft, sind deutlich höher, als wenn man das Kupfer benutzt. Was dazu auch noch liegt normalerweise im Haus.
Also bei uns wären es halt 60 Parteien pro Häuserblock, weil das noch so ein schöner Plattenbau ist. Da kommt schon einiges zusammen. Und das ist richtig bei so einem Einfamilienhaus, da kommt halt einmal ein Techniker von Stadtwerken, macht das einmal im Keller, dann ist das angeschlossen. Und im Wohnzimmer, Schlafzimmerflug, wo auch immer, ist eine Dose mit dem Stecker. Das heißt, das muss einmal gemacht werden, solange das Kabel nicht rausgerissen wird oder kaputt gemacht wird, kann das so bleiben. Also ist halt ein initialer Aufwand, der einmal betrieben werden muss. Das ist richtig.
Und gibt es schon Erkenntnisse über die, sozusagen, die nicht vergammelizit hätte? Also was ich sagen will, ihr sagt ja, das Kupfer liegt da schon seit Jahrzehnten und so. Aber anscheinend funktioniert das auch nach Jahrzehnten noch. Wie ist das mit Glasfaser?
70 Jahre mindestens.
Also um es ein bisschen präziser zu sagen, vielleicht, wenn jemand ein bisschen Ahnung hat von Materialwissenschaften. Also, da ist Glas drin, Glas ist hygroskopisch. Das heißt, es zieht Wasserstoffatome ins Glas rein, wenn das Glas offen liegt und damit wird das Glas trüb. Wenn man mal ein sehr altes Glas hat, was man nun vorhat, dann hat man so einen milchigen Schleier drauf. Und das kann auch ein Glasfaserkabel treffen. Deswegen werden die Glasfaserkabel normalerweise in so einer Schutzhülle transportiert. Da ist meist so ein Gel drin, was das Wasser anzieht, sodass die Faser möglichst lange hält. Es spricht nichts dagegen, dass die Kabel, die im Boden liegen, 100 Jahre und länger halten, wenn die professionell an den Enden abgeschlossen worden sind.
Jetzt haben wir noch eine weitere Frage. Johannes, du hattest vorhin irgendwas erzählt mit, es gab eine Beschwerde an den DSL. Bitte kannst du das noch mal kurz erläutern?
Ja, das war der Punkt, den wir vor den Nachrichten hatten, dass wir über die Reichweiten von DSL-Signalen und so weiter gesprochen haben. Und ich habe das gerade noch mal nachgeschaut. Die Bundesnetzagentur, die hat Messungen an 160.000 DSL-Anschlüssen durchgeführt und festgestellt, dass bei der Hälfte der Kunden weniger als 60 Prozent der versprochenen Leistung ankommt. Und das ist genau die Ursache dafür, ist genau dieses Problem, dass wir vor der Nachrichtenpause besprochen haben, dass DSL eben je länger das Signal gehen muss, desto schwächer wird es. Und dann gibt es eben noch die Interferenzen mit anderen Kabeln und so weiter. Und dadurch hat man halt am Ende ein suboptimales Produkt, mit dem die Kunden in der Regel auch nicht zufrieden sind, weil sie eben sagen, ich wollte 16 Embit haben, krieg nur 10.
Und das, sozusagen, wir setzen wieder zum Glasfaser zurück. Wie ist es denn da? Ist da die Reichweite auch begrenzt oder?
Ja, begrenzt ist sie natürlich. Aber ich sag mal, wir haben genug Sicherheit an Übertragungsqualität in der Glasfaser drin, als das zumindest bei dem, was heute an Produkt denkbar ist, eigentlich nirgendwo es ernstzunehmende Probleme geben wird.
Also man sagt normalerweise, dass wenn ich ein Kabel zwischen Hamburg und Berlin lege, ein Glasfaserkabel, dass ich so alle 100, 200 Kilometer in Verstärker setzen muss, damit das Signal wieder aufgefrischt wird, das optische Signal, was da übertragen wird, das Licht. Im Stadtbereich sind die Kabel, die da verlegt werden, durchaus in der Lage 100 Kilometer und mehr zu machen. Das ist nicht das Problem des Kabels, sondern eher der der Optik des Lasers, wie Mutags ja schon gesagt hatte. Das, was man da am Ende ransteckt, wo man das Glasfaserkabel reinsteckt, diese Module sind extrem preiswert, wenn man nicht mehr als 10-15 Kilometer macht. Dann sind die in einem Preisbereich weit unter 50 Euro, wenn man sie einkauft.
Aber warte mal.
Dadurch kommt die Entfernung.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Momentan ist es ja so, dass das Internet sozusagen läuft, also das, man spricht immer vom Backbone, da gibt es so riesige, dicke, meterticke Kabel und das wird dann immer kleiner. Es kommt eine Kästen von der Straße und dann geht es in das Haus rein. Das heißt, das sind immer sozusagen Umstellstationen mehr oder weniger. Ist es beim Glasfaser auch so oder wird das dann tatsächlich so sein? Also ich hatte jetzt vorgestellt, es gibt auch diese grauen Kästen und dann wird eine Straße davon versorgt.
Genau so kann das gebaut werden, eine mögliche Option, dass man im Grunde sagt, man stellt sich so eine Straße vor, da legt man jetzt ein Kabel die Straße lang, jedes Haus wird da von dem Kabel mit Fasern versorgt, so viel das Haushalt braucht, wie viele Mietsparteien da drin sind und in dem Kasten kommt dieses Kabel an und dann kann in diesem Kasten ein aktives Gerät stehen, also irgendwas, was Strom verbraucht, das wandelt das dieses optische Lichtsignal, was da aus jeder Wohnung kommt, in ein elektrisches Signal um und dann steht da sowas, ich meine, der Vergleich hinkt zwar extremer, sowas wie ein AVM-Router, den man auch hat, aber ein paar Nummern größer, der hängt dann am anderen Ende an dem Backboden dran, den du erwähnt hast, der dann im Prinzip das Internet an diesen Kasten ran transportiert. Und der Teilnehmer selber, ja.
Wäre das dann auch, also sagen, das nächst dickere Kabel, wäre das auch wieder Glasfaser?
Das wäre auch wieder Glasfaser, ja.
Okay, ich versuch mal gerade sofort, ob man nicht die kleinen Lichter, dann das große Licht irgendwie so rein.
Das kann man auch machen.
Das geht tatsächlich. Also, weil, so wie du es gerade beschrieben hast, dann sagen, wandle ich ja den Glasfaser, also den Lichtimpuls in einen elektrischen, sozusagen Binary-01-Stromding um und mach das dann wieder zurück in das dickere Kabel. Aber man kann es auch sozusagen, das Licht zusammenspleißen. Das hört sich so zeitgibusig an.
Ja, es gibt halt auch verschiedenste Optionen. Es gibt halt die eine Sache, die Stefan schon vorhin erwähnt hat, dass man halt mit verschiedenen Farben arbeitet. Und es gibt die andere Möglichkeit, dass man quasi sozusagen Y-Stücke einsetzt. Kann man sich wirklich vorstellen, wie dieses schöne Y-Stück beim Gartenschlauch, was man hat.
Das Kabel wird zu kleineren Kabel, bzw. kleinere Kabel werden zu einem großen Kabel.
Genau, da kann man dann über eine Glasfaser bis zu 64 Leute mit anschließen.
Was ich gerade fragen wollte, ist, weil die die Farben immer erwähnt haben. Ich dachte jetzt, okay, rot, grün, gelb, blau. Wie viele Farben kriegt man denn in einem Kabel unter?
Man spricht da, es ist ja, also Farbe ist zu viel gesagt. Das ist nicht rot, grün, blau, was wir da haben. Das liegt bei, im Infrarotbereich, wenn man das kennt, so bei 800 Nanometer ist das kleinste, aber wir arbeiten bei 1500 Nanometer. Das sieht man auch nicht mehr. So ein Ultraviolettbereich müsste das sein und darauf kann man so 200 bis 400 Kanäle übertragen, bezahlbar übertragen und da wird mutags gleich wieder sagen, in der Wissenschaft kriegt man da sicher auch 1000 oder mehr rein.
Wir wollen ja heute übers Internet zu Hause reden.
Zu Hause sind 200, ist eine gute Zahl. Das kriegt man heute auch gut rein multiplexed.
So, dann letzte Frage für diese halbe Stunde ist, wir haben ja gerade gehört, im Kupfer-Internet kommen 60% an oder sogar noch weniger, in vielen Fällen. Und das liegt also nicht an der Böswilligkeit der Betreiber, also nicht direkt sozusagen, sondern einfach an der technischen Gegebenheit, die das Kupferkabel im Haus macht. Da wird mit den Augen gerollt, aber im Prinzip stimmt es so. Die Frage ist, oder andersrum gesagt, es gibt eine denkbare Situation, wo die Abnahme der versprochenen Bandbreite nur an den Kupferunzulänglichkeiten liegt. Wie ist das mit dem Glasfaserkabel? Wenn mir der Anbieter sagt, okay, 250 Mbit kriegst du, wir stecken das in diesen grauen Kasten da rein, kommt das dann auch bei mir in der Wohnung an?
In der Wohnung kommt mindestens immer ein Gigabit an oder 100 Mbit oder 10 Gigabit.
Was ist das Kleinste?
Das Kleinste ist 100 Megabit.
Kleiner macht das nicht?
Kleiner, man könnte 10 Megabit, aber da sind die Optiken in der Zwischenzeit schon viel zu teuer, weil das Vintage-Technologie ist.
Aber die 100 Mbit fallen aus dem Kasten in meinen Kabel rein, was zu mir nach Hause geht. Und das kommt dann auch an.
Genau, und wenn du aber 250 hast, dann hast du einen Gigabit Anschluss und der Provider drosselt die Leitung an seinem Aktiven, da wo das vom Optischen ins Elektrische gewandelt wird, drosselt die Geschwindigkeit auf ein Viertel, nämlich auf die 250. Das wird aber elektronisch gemacht mit einem Kommando an dem Gerät.
Gibt es da Gründe für das zu machen?
Es gibt einen sehr guten Grund dafür. Es gibt ausreichend viele Geschäftskunden, die Glasfaser in ihren Büros liegen haben. Und im Preisvergleich zu machen, die bezahlen für die 2 MBit symmetrische Leitung in ihre Häuser, zum Teil 250 Euro im Monat.
Gibt es nicht ökonomische Gründe, das zu machen?
Nein.
Gut. Dann sprechen wir gleich in der nächsten Stunde darüber, was denn jetzt eigentlich mit dem Glasfaserausbau ist und wie wir da hinkommen. Keegan Whitney, The Castle's All Alone von The Differences Album. Kann man sich kostenlos runterladen und weitergeben, ist Creative Commons Musik und das bedeutet, ihr seid im Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Und dort reden wir heute darüber, wie wir vielleicht alle mal möglichst breitbandiges, möglichst schnelles Internet zu uns nach Hause bekommen können. Und dafür begrüße ich zurück den Johannes, den Stefan, den Filz in den Mutagshalonen. So, wir haben also quasi den Point of No Return unterschritten. Ich kann euch jetzt die erste Stunde nicht mehr in einem Satz zusammenfassen, aber kann kurz sagen, wir haben festgestellt, wir brauchen mehr Internet zu Hause. Und das geht nicht mit dem Kupferkabel, was über das ihr normales DSL bekommt, sondern dafür will man eigentlich Glasfaserkabel haben, weil die schnelleres und mehr und besseres Internet machen. Und wollen jetzt mal darüber sprechen, warum das nicht so passiert, wie man sich das vorstellt. Und da würde ich sozusagen noch einen fünften Gast mit ins Boot holen. Ich habe das vor der Sendung kurz mit ihm gesprochen, nämlich mit Heiko Liebscher von Wilhelm Tell. Das kann er eigentlich gleich selber erzählen. Es geht darum, wie ist das denn eigentlich, wenn man den Plan hat, Glasfaser überhören zu bringen, was passiert denn da? Und ich habe den Heiko Liebscher erst mal gefragt. Wilhelm Tell, erklär doch mal bitte genau, was ist denn das?
Ja, Wilhelm Tell ist ein kleiner Seeking-Netzbetreiber, der 1999 gegründet wurde, befindet sich im Norden von Hamburg, hat eine ganze Stadt, also 32.000 Haushalte, mit Glasfaser versorgt, schon 1999, baut dementsprechend viel aus und hat jetzt auch 200.000 Anschlüsse in Hamburg rein mit Glasfaser bis zum Kunden.
Was für, über welche Bandbreiten sprechen wir da?
Ja, also wir sind ja mal ganz am Anfang gestartet mit 10 Megabit, dann 100 Megabit und inzwischen sind wir tatsächlich so, dass wir über die Glasfaser, über den Medienkonverter Gigabit haben. Zurzeit wird das Produkt als 250 Megabit-Produkt vermarktet, wird aber in diesem Jahr halt als Option dann auch bis zum Gigabit angeboten werden.
Ich will jetzt sozusagen nicht über genaue Preise sprechen, weil es keine Werbeveranstaltung werden soll, aber nur wissen, wenn man das sich als jemand als Privatperson holt, dann spielt sich das, ich sag mal, im üblichen Rahmen ab.
Also das ist in einem üblichen Rahmen, wo wir sonst eher mit einem 100 Megabit-Anschluss rechnen. Also, wer unsere Preise kennt, der weiß, dass wir also marktgerechte Preise haben, sonst kann man natürlich in diesem großen Wettbewerb nicht bestehen, aber selbstverständlich kann sich das eine Privatperson leisten.
Also die sind sozusagen, ich sag mal, normal bezahlbar. Warum gibt sie nicht schon überall diese Anschlüsse?
Ja, das liegt teilweise daran, dass die Glasfaser oder der Glasfaserausbau durch das Vectoring-Produkt der Telekom natürlich behindert wird. Dadurch wird eine alte Technologie, die, ja, ich sag mal, schon seit mehreren Jahren im Boden ist, die teilweise abgeschrieben ist, halt versucht, länger zu beleben und dann noch mehr höhere Bandbreiten zu bekommen. Aber letztendlich kann man über Kupfer ja heute natürlich auch 100 Megabit übertragen. Und es gibt andere Technologien, wo ich aber immer weiter dichter zum Kunden muss, auch mit meiner Glasfaser. Selbst die Telekom geht ja mit einer Glasfaser bis vor den KVZ, vor das Haus und macht den letzten Meter nur am Kupfer. Aber wenn man gleich mit Glasfaser zum Kunden gehen würde, hätte man natürlich die Bandbreiten direkt heute schon verfügbar.
Naja, aber sozusagen, das kann ja sein, das ist verschiedene Angebote. Aber was konkret hindert Wilhelm Tell daran, bei allen zu sein?
Ja, uns hindert ganz konkret, ich sag mal die Aussage, dass wir mit dem Breitbandausbau in Deutschland mit 50 Megabit uns zufriedenheben und nicht mit 100 Megabit oder Gigabit. Also es wird im Augenblick natürlich nichts gefördert, was wirklich rein glastechnisch ausgebaut ist. Und teilweise wird natürlich das, was in Glas ausgebaut wurde, durch die Telekom überbaut, beziehungsweise durch Vectoring, werden die Gebäude erschlossen und die Telekom hat dann ein Alleinversorgungsrecht in den Gebäuden.
Also das heißt sozusagen bei den Gebäuden, wo Glasfaser schon dran oder in der Nähe liegt, kommt man als andere anbieter, der nicht die Telekom ist, einfach nicht ran?
Genau.
Und jetzt fehlt gerade der Begriff Förderung. Das bedeutet, es würde sich nicht alleine lohnen, dass selber sozusagen alles zu bauen, sondern da bedürfte es staatlicher Förderung?
Na ja, zumindestens müsste man einfach dafür sorgen, ich sag mal von einer Regulierungsbehörde, dass Glasfaserausgebaute Gebiete dann auch Richtung Open Access geöffnet werden. Und mit dem Open Access dann auch die Telekom verpflichtet werden würde, auf diesem Netz, auf diesem Glasfasernetz seine Kunden zu versorgen. Damit würde man natürlich das Netz deutlich besser auslasten und die Effektivität und Wirtschaftlichkeit deutlich besser.
Das verstehe ich nicht ganz. Heißt das sozusagen, eine dritte Partei soll die Glasfasernetze bauen und dann soll jeder Anbieter darüber seinen Internetverkehr routen? Oder würde William Tell zum Beispiel selber auch was bauen und dann macht das jeder und dann haben wir irgendwann ganz Deutschland glasgefasert?
Also es wäre praktisch, also meiner Meinung nach ist es egal, ob ein Dritter das ausbaut und alle anderen nutzen das. Oder William Tell das ausbaut, nur dann nicht nochmal ein zweiter Parallel, eine Kochverbindung aufrüstet mit Vectoring oder nochmal überbaut, sondern dass man dann halt als zweiter mindestens diese vorhandenen Glasfasereinschlüsse benutzen kann.
Also überbauen heißt, nur um es mal noch kurz nachzufragen, das heißt einfach jemand anderes legt auch noch eine Leitung, irgendwo wo schon eine liegt?
Ja, also es ist ja so, selbst wenn wir jetzt ein Gebäude erschließen mit Glas, dann ist ja meistens schon Kupfer vorhanden durch die Telekom, weil ja fast jedes Gebäude erschlossen ist. Und wenn man jetzt Vectoring zusätzlich einbaut in den KVZs, um dann die alte Kupferleitung nochmal auf 100 Megabit fähig zu machen, obwohl es schon Glasfasereinschluss in dem Haus gibt, das macht für mich in meiner Meinung nach keinen Sinn. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Gibt es konkrete Forderungen, die Wilhelm Tell dann stellt, wo sie sagt, okay, da müsste vielleicht, keine Ahnung, eine Regulierungsbehörde oder die Politik im Allgemeinen oder irgendjemand irgendwas machen, damit das in Zukunft anders wird?
Ja, also der Glasfaserausbau sollte als Einziges gefördert werden. Damit würde auch die Telekom und andere Netzbetreiber verpflichtet werden, sozusagen dann in neueste Technologien bis zum Kunden zu investieren. Und das, ich sag mal, was heute in Glasfaser ausgebaut ist, kann man ja dann durch Open Access allen möglichen Mitbewerbern öffnen. Also wir machen das im Open Access-Bereich ja so, dass wir mehrere große Anbieter schon heute durchlassen. Also wir haben in Hamburg 25.000 Durchleitungskunden von einer Telefonika oder einer 1&1. Gerade Infrastruktur betreiben.
Halko Liebscher von Wilhelm Tell war das, ein kleiner Anbieter aus dem Norden Deutschlands und hat uns mal erklärt, woran es beim Glasfaserausbau so haken kann. Seine Forderungen sind zusammengefasst, es gibt tatsächlich sozusagen Fördergelder für den Breitbandausbau in Deutschland. Er sagt, die sollen nur noch für Glasfaser verwendet werden und die Glasfaser, die gebaut werden und wurden, sollten sozusagen geöffnet werden. Das heißt, da soll dann nicht nur ein Anbieter drauf dürfen und die benutzen dürfen, sondern mehrere. So, wenn in Deutschland irgendwas mit der Telekommunikation schief läuft, rufen alle immer, die Telekom ist schuld. Wie ist es wirklich, lieber Anwesende?
Stimmt doch auch.
Ich würde da mal gegensätzlich in meinem vertreten. Es ist nicht nur die Deutsche Telekom, die Schwierigkeit liegt darin, dass die Anreize fehlen. Und ich glaube, der Heiko Liebscher hat das auch ganz gut beschrieben. Wenn die Einreize da wären und die Kunden auch aufgeklärter wären, dann wäre das auch einfacher. Die Telekom ist nicht der einzige Access-Anbieter, den wir in Deutschland haben. Die großen drei, der zweite Telefoniker wurde eben auch schon genannt, das ist auch die Vodafone mit den Kabelfernsehnetzen, die sie jetzt dazu bekommen haben. Die alle drei gehen nicht diesen Weg, weil sie immer noch die Abschreibung haben wollen, weil es immer noch attraktiver ist, sich die Fördergelder für den DSL-Ausbau zu besorgen.
Bevor wir zu großen Föhn kommen, du hast gerade den Satz gesagt, die Kunden müssen aufgeklärt werden. Ich als Kunde bin aufgeklärt, in der Hinsicht, dass ich denke, ich möchte möglichst gern breitbandiges viel Internet her damit. Was meinst du mit Kunden aufklären?
Die Marketing-Abteilung der Unternehmen haben einen sehr guten Job darin getan, ein hochwertiges Produkt zu kreieren, was durch drei Buchstaben definiert ist, nämlich diese DSL, Digital Subscription Line. Wenn man das ins Deutsche übersetzt, ist das nichts weiter als eine digitale Übertragungsleitung. Das kann Glasfaser oder Kupfer sein. Aber die Leute assoziieren mit einem hochwertigen Internetanschluss immer ein DSL-Produkt. Damit auch damals mal ADSL, heute VDSL und AVDSL 2. Keiner kommt auf die Idee, so was wie GDSL oder so einzuführen, Glasfaser DSL, und ich glaube, dass es so auf diese einfache Formel zurückzuführen ist.
Ja, aber was ich mich frage, es gibt ja sozusagen einen wirtschaftlichen Raum, und diesem wirtschaftlichen Raum ist auch Platz für Anbieter, wie dem, was wir gerade gehört haben. Und ich frage mich schon, warum geht denn nicht einfach jemand hin und sagt, ich bau da jetzt in dieser Straße dieses Glasfaserding ein, und dann werden schon Kunden kommen. Also worauf wird denn da gewartet? Ich meine, man wartet anscheinend darauf, dass die Großen das irgendwie machen, aber...
Ja und nein. Also ich kann ein bisschen erzählen, wie das bei meinen Eltern passiert ist. Da haben die Stadtwerke gesagt, wir machen genau das. Die Stadtwerke, ich sag einfach mal, wo das ist, das ist in Marburg, die haben die letzten 10, 15 Jahre schon immer versucht, Internet zu den Leuten zu bringen. Die haben angefangen mit Richtfunksstrecken, die sie übers plattelande auf Funktürme gesetzt haben, und von da aus in die Dörfer gegangen sind, und da dann auch per WLAN und per Richtfunksstrecke in die einzelnen Privathaushalte Internet gebracht haben. Und die haben jetzt angefangen, dass sie gesagt haben, die Bandbreiten, die wir darüber kriegen, reichen nicht mehr. Wir machen das auch Glasfaser. Dann haben sie halt ein Jahr lang gebuddelt. Und ab dem Moment, ab dem sie gesagt haben, dass sie jetzt Glasfaser anbieten, da kamen dann auch zum Beispiel die Telekom und andere Anbieter und haben sehr günstige Angebote gemacht, die unter dem Preis waren, die das Glasfaser kosten würde. Und haben in den Prospekten behauptet, ja, das ist auch alles ganz schnell, weil wir bündeln jetzt euren langsam DSL-Anschluss mit LTE. Und wenn ich da jetzt als Kunde jetzt diesem Vollsprechen allen glaube und das kaufe, heißt das A, dass ganz viele Nachbarhäuser eben nicht diesen Glasfaseranschluss kaufen. Das heißt, für die Stadtwerke wird es dann teurer, das auszubauen, weil sie weniger Kunden haben, aber den gleichen Aufwand, die Straße aufzureißen erst mal. Und die Kunden haben das Gefühl, naja, ich kriege da billiger von der Telekom-Anschluss, der angeblich genauso schnell ist. Und ich brauche ja auch gar nicht so schnell das Internet. Ich mache da ja eigentlich gar nicht so viel. Und dann reicht das. Und hinterher stellt man fest, dass dann die LTE-Funktionelle halt überbucht ist, es alles langsam ist, vor allem abends. Und dann geht das alles nicht und Leute sind unglücklich. Das verhindert natürlich auch einen Ausbau, weil das sehen wir deutschlandweit, dass sobald kleinere Anbieter auf den Markt kommen und versuchen Glasfaser auszubauen, dann plötzlich die Großen kommen und sagen, jetzt müssen wir in diesem Markt hier in dieses Dorf wohl doch mal Glasfaser hinlegen und da irgendwie DSL ausbauen, weil sonst haben wir dieses Dorf verloren.
Und wenn einer der Großen sich jetzt entscheiden würde, zu sagen, wir machen den großen Umbau oder den großen Ausbau, der Erste ist derjenige, bei dem der Aktienkurs eindringt, weil sie das Geld jetzt erstmal für 20 Jahre in den Boden verseckt haben, bis es wieder reinkommt. Und es ist derjenige, der erstmal die Kosten hat. Das heißt, es ist das klassische Beamten-Mikado. Wer sich zuerst bewegt, hat den großen Nachteil.
Und mich der Dritte jetzt in der Runde. Man sollte auch mal ganz genau zuhören, was der Heiko gesagt hat. Der Heiko hat gesagt, dass er das, was er da gebaut hat, das Glasfaser nicht nur für seine eigenen Produkte gebaut hat, sondern er hat diese Glasfaser auch an andere vermietet und verkauft. Es ist wesentlich leichter, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, Infrastruktur aufzubauen. Und wenn der Mieter in einem Haus zum Beispiel die freie Auswahl hat, welchen Provider er gerne hätte und der Provider, der da nicht selber ausgebaut hat, sich einfach die Faser, den Zugang dazu mietet. Das ist ein Volksmodell, was übrigens sehr gut auch im Ausland funktioniert. Man muss nicht immer alles selber in die Häuser bauen. Man kann das auch anmieten. Damit wird es auch leichter für kleinere Provider, einen, wie sagt man so schön, Business Case daraus zu machen und damit auch Geld zu verdienen.
Ja, aber jetzt bin ich wieder verwirrt, weil was du gesagt hast, Stefan, lässt mich noch mal die Frage stellen, warum passiert das dann nicht? Also es passiert sozusagen lokal eingeschränkt, aber das ist doch ein ganz hervorragendes Modell. Ich gehe hierhin als kleiner Anbietersager so hier, ich leg dir Glasfaser ins Haus, ich vermiete das an die großen Anbieter. Also worauf genau warten die Leute? Und ich find auch komisch, dass du das Filz gesagt hast, wer es zuerst bewegt, fällt um, weil es ist doch absehbar, dass wir so viel Internet brauchen oder nicht.
Aber ich kann doch noch Geld machen, ohne das Geld zu investieren. Warum sollte ich es also tun?
Na weil du dann der Erste bist und sagen, die Kunden dann zu dir kommen. Weil du dann entweder sozusagen ganz viele neue Kunden hast oder diese Glasfaser, die du gelegt hast, an andere Anbieter verwenden kannst.
Aber es ist doch egal, solange niemand ausbaut, verliert dir auch niemand.
Irgendwann crash das halt, aber dann haben wir alle verloren. Dann sind wir aber wieder bei den kleinen Anbietern, die sagen, naja, wenn die großen das nicht machen, dann machen wir das halt.
Das Problem ist, dass so ein kleiner Anbieter es nicht flächendeckend anbieten kann. Das heißt, wenn ein kleiner Anbieter das in seinem Bereich macht, kommt halt sofort ein großer Anbieter und unterbietet ihn und nimmt ihm im Prinzip die Kunden weg, was ich eben von Stadtwerken erzählt habe.
Aber dafür haben wir doch eine Regulierungsbehörde, oder nicht?
Aber der Markt ist doch nicht reguliert. Reguliert wird der Markt in dem Moment, in dem es einen großen gibt, der den Markt so sehr beherrscht, dass er reguliert werden muss.
Also es gibt doch die Bundesnetzagentur.
Ja, die gerade erlaubt hat, dass die Telekom allein Vectoring machen darf auf ihren KVZ.
So, dann erklärt mir mal, wie das jetzt sozusagen, also es gibt doch wahrscheinlich einen Plan, wie das doch noch klappen kann. Also ich fasse mal zusammen, was ich von euch mitbekommen habe. Die kleinen Anbieter machen es nicht, weil sie dann von den Großen ausgebotet werden. Die großen Anbieter machen es nicht, weil sie noch sehr lange Geld verdienen können. Damit ist nicht zu machen. Und die Bundesnetzagentur, die eigentlich die Stelle wäre, die sagen könnte, so Leute, ihr verhindert aktiv eine Technologie, die wir dringend brauchen. Ihr macht jetzt das jetzt mal oder wir fördern die kleinen. Die sozusagen hält die Füße still und sagt so, Vectoring, diese völlig veraltete Technologie, wo die Kupferkabel im Haus weiter benutzt werden, die ist total super.
Na ja, was du machen kannst, ist selber aktiv werden. Also als das im Dorf von meinen Eltern anfing, habe ich halt meinen Eltern erklärt, warum sie Glasfaser haben möchten, warum sie nicht dieses Alternativprodukt haben möchten, und dass sie bitte allen ihren Nachbarn das auch erklären sollen. Und ich glaube zwei Drittel oder 70 Prozent der gesamten Häuser in diesem Ort haben jetzt Glasfaser und werden demnächst nicht mehr bei der Telekom-Kunden sein. Also wenn die zwei Jahre Vertragslaufzeit abgelaufen sind, wo die Leute noch alle drinstecken. Das heißt, du musst halt selber Leute aktiv überzeugen und erklären, dass sie auch wenn es jetzt erstmal mehr kostet, sie vielleicht Glasfaser wirklich kaufen wollen, auch mit den Nachbarn zusammen das machen wollen, um dann auf lange Sicht auch was davon zu haben. Weil letztlich werden diese Häuser in dem Ort, die Glasfaser haben, später auch für teures Geld verkauft werden. Weil nachträglich kommt das nicht mehr.
Das kann ich machen, wenn ich auch Eltern habe, die in einem Dorf leben, was ich nicht habe. Aber ich mein, um habe ich das falsch im Kopf, ist in der Politik doch in der ganzen Zeit von Breitbandausbau geredet, oder nicht? Wollen wir Deutschland irgendwie zu Breitbandland werden und so was? Gibt es nicht irgendwie so bunte Broschüren?
Ja, haben wir sogar eine gerade hier. Was ist das Ziel bis 2030? 50 Megabit oder so. Und das ist halt genau zufälligerweise das, was diesem Vectoring geht. Also Hauptsache keine neue Technik.
Das ist doch unfassbar. Fils, du bist doch jetzt, wie heißt der Verein, wo du bist? Oder der Anbieter?
Ich bin bei In Berlin.
In Berlin. Und ihr baut sowas selber?
Wir haben damals angefangen, wie ESDN Einwahl und Modemeinwahl für die Leute anzubieten. Aber im Prinzip mit dem DSL-Markt ist es fast nicht mehr möglich, zu den Leuten nach Hause irgendwelche Technik zu legen. ESDN, sie sind halt wirklich in Reichweite, dass man ein bisschen Richtfunk machen kann. Weil die Zugangskosten, wenn man jetzt Leitungen von der Telekom anmieten muss, wir haben in Berlin 40 Hauptverteiler. 140 Hauptverteiler. In jedem müsste man eine Leitung legen. In jedem müsste man sich von der Telekom Fläche anmieten. Das Geld kann man als kleiner überhaupt nicht aufbringen.
Das heißt zu sagen, das ist momentan nur noch ein Verein, der für die alten Zeiten da ist, aber...
Nein, wir bieten Hosting an, wir bieten es den Leuten an, dass sie ihren eigenen Server bei uns unterstellen können.
Ich wollte sagen, fürs Internet nach Hause bringen.
Aber fürs Internet nach Hause bieten können wir den Leuten nur sagen, ihr könnt VPN mit einer festen IP-Adresse bekommen und dann im Prinzip durch einen Tunnel, durch euren DSL-Anschluss, direkt durchtunneln.
Genau, da brauch ich ja schon mal Internet. Ich muss noch kurz fragen, du hast am Anfang gesagt, du hast dein eigenes Internet gemacht.
Ich habe ursprünglich dafür gesorgt, dass wir die Einwahltechnik haben, dass wir in der Lage sind, wir haben dafür gesorgt, dass wir in der Lage sind, uns halt über das Telefonnetz, was damals die einzige Möglichkeit war, Internet nach Hause zu bekommen. Das war der ursprüngliche Zweck.
Mit eigener IP-Adresse, mit Diensten, die man anbieten kann und so weiter und so fort.
Ohne dass einem einer in die Suppe spuckt und vielleicht irgendwelche Dienste, die man gerne hat, runtershaped oder filtert.
Okay, aber sagen, ihr könnt auch keinen Glasfaser herzaubern?
Nein.
Schade.
Das Grundproblem mit dem Glasfaser ist, der Business Case wurde angesprochen, die Verlegekosten innerhalb der Stadt sind extrem hoch. Denn die Glasfaser wird heute noch auch zu den Häusern in einer Qualität verlegt, die für Rechenzentren geeignet ist. Also mit einer fast hundertprozentigen Verfügbarkeit. Jeder DSL-Anschluss und jeder, der sich mal seine allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen durchgelesen hat, hat eine schlechtere. Meist unter 90 Prozent sogar. Das heißt, wenn man die Glasfaserkabel mit demselben Verfügbarkeit verlegen würde, Schlitzverlegung, nur 10, 20 Zentimeter unter dem Gehsteig, eine Plattenreihe aufnehmen, würde man, und ich bin jetzt kein Tiefbauingenieur, aber ich würde mal aus dem Bau heraus sagen, ein zwanzigstel Kosten pro laufendem Meter haben. Und damit wird es auch einfacher, auch für so ein Innenberlin vielleicht mal eine Straße mit Glas zu versorgen. Aber solange das nicht möglich ist oder wo der Hemmschuh liegt, ob das die Bezirksämter, die Bauämter sind, wer da blockiert, das müsste man mal genauer evaluieren. Aber es scheint da ein Problem zu geben.
Okay, gut. Wir sprechen noch gleich genauer über das Problem, machen vorher noch eine kurze Pause, gibt noch einmal Musik von King White-Nay, dann gibt es die Nachrichten und dann sozusagen, ich möchte in einer halben Stunde noch wissen, wie ich, wenn wir uns nächstes Jahr an dieser Stelle wieder treffen, mindestens ein Gigabit zu Hause bei mir zu liegen habe.
Das erste Lollapaloozer hier in der Gegend fandet ihr...
Mega.
Das zweite Lollapaloozer war eher so...
Der Wahnsinn, wirklich. Mega, hammergeil.
Geile Party. Und das dritte Lollapaloozer wird... All das plus Hui mal zwei hoch Fritz.
Fritz präsentiert...
Das Lollapaloozer Festival. Mit dabei... Mumford & Sons... Crow und die Foo Fighters. Und The X-Ex. Marshmallow... Und Materia. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Diesmal auf der Rennbahn Hoppergarten. Wer da noch alles auftritt und wo man Karten kaufen oder sogar gewinnen kann, fritz.de slash lala.
Der absolute Ebershit präsentiert von Fritz.
Fritz Nachrichten mit Martin Schneider.
Die britische Regierung hat ihre Pläne für den Weg zum Brexit vorgestellt. Der zuständige Minister Davies kündigte in London ein Gesetz an, mit dem zunächst die Geltung von EU-Recht in Großbritannien aufgehoben werden soll. Damit es durch den Austritt nicht zum Chaos kommt, sollen gleichzeitig mehr als 10.000 EU-Vorschriften in nationales Recht übertragen werden. Nach und nach sollen sie geprüft und gegebenenfalls geändert werden. Streit dürfte es über die Pläne der konservativen Regierung geben, einzelne Vorschriften ohne Zustimmung des Parlaments zu ändern. Der Bundestag hat dem Gesetzentwurf für mehr Lohngleichheit zwischen Frauen und Männer beschlossen. Nach der neuen Regelung müssen Arbeitnehmer in Betrieben mit mehr als 200 Beschäftigten über die Bezahlung von Kollegen mit vergleichbaren Aufgaben informiert werden. Der Bundestag hat außerdem einem Gesetzentwurf zum automatisierten Fahren auf deutschen Straßen zugestimmt. Künftig dürfen damit Computer in Autos die Steuerung übernehmen. Der Fahrer muss aber jederzeit eingreifen können. Hunderte Menschen in Südbrandenburg müssen nicht für den Braunkohletagebau umziehen. Die Pläne zum Ausbau des Tagebaus in der Lausitz werden deutlich gekürzt. Das gab der Energiekonzern LEAG am Abend bekannt. Demnach wird der Tagebau Jens Schwalde nicht weitergeführt, weil das dazugehörige 40 Jahre alte Kraftwerk technisch nicht mehr zeitgemäß sei. Ob jedoch der Tagebau Weltsow Süd noch erweitert wird, will die LEAG bis 2020 entscheiden. Die Deutschen essen immer weniger Fleisch. Letztes Jahr lag der Fleischkonsum pro Kopf im Schnitt bei 60 Kilo. Das hat die Bundesanstalt für Landwirtschaft und Ernährung ausgerechnet. Vor 20 Jahren hat jeder Deutsche statistisch noch 8 Kilo mehr gegessen. Am beliebtesten ist Schweinefleisch. Das machte letztes Jahr einen Anteil von 60 Prozent aus. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Marzahn 13 Grad, in Wilmersdorf 15, Frankfurt-Oder und Ludwigsfelde 13 Grad, Joachimsthal 14 und Pritzwerg sogar noch 16 Grad. Bis zum Morgen werden die Wolken weniger, es bleibt trocken bei minimal 10 bis 6 Grad. Morgen gibt es dann viel Sonne und bis zu 25 Grad. Es gibt ein paar Vollsperrungen, alle bis morgen früh um 5, nämlich auf der A100 Stadtring Richtung Knoikölln zwischen dem Jakob-Kaiserplatz und Hohenzollern-Damm, auf der A111 Stadt Autobahn Richtung Dreik-Charlotten-Bürg zwischen Hecker-Damm und Dreik-Charlotten-Bürg und auch auf der A115-Avus statt einwärts ist im Dreik-Funktum die Überleitung zur A100 Richtung Wilmersdorf gesperrt. Ansonsten Rollz, daraus geht euch eine gute Fahrt.
Pritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Ihr hört das Chaos-Radio im Blue Moon und dort gibt es natürlich immer die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Mo, vorgetragen von Martin Schneider.
Bundestag fordert vertrauenswürdige Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung. Die Große Koalition fordert sichere elektronische Kommunikation und vertrauenswürdige Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung. In einem Antrag zum innovativen Staat wird verlangt, sichere und vertrauenswürdige Verschlüsselungsverfahren sowie deren Implementierung und einfache Handhabbarkeit zu fördern und zu unterstützen. Für den Antrag stimmten die Fraktionen der SPD und CDU und CSU. Die Grünen enthielten sich, die Linke stimmte gegen den Antrag. Hackerangriff auf den Bundestag. Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik berichtet über einen erneuten Cyberangriff auf den Bundestag, der aber abgewehrt wurde. Nach der Analyse des BSI scheint es sich dabei, um einen Malvatizing-Angriff auf einer Nachrichtenseite gehandelt zu haben, die keinen signifikanten Einfluss auf die überwachten Netze gehabt hat. Das BSI hat keine Schadsoftware entdeckt, auch Infektionen sind nicht bekannt.
Das war die NerdNews von Matten Schneider, vielen Dank! Eine halbe Stunde noch im Chaosradio im Blue Moon und willkommen zurück. Montags, nabend, Stefan, hallo und Johannes. Wir wollen noch eine halbe Stunde darüber reden, warum wir noch kein breitbandiges Internet per Glasfaser zu Hause haben. Ich möchte kurz einen kleinen Schwenker machen. Habt ihr es in den NerdNews gerade gehört? Also die Regierung fordert Verschlüsselung und CDU und SPD stimmen dafür und der Rest dagegen? Oder enthalten sich? Was ist da los? Das ist eine völlig verkehrte Welt.
Ich habe keinen Blassen.
Das müssen wir nochmal genauer. Also das würde mich ja nochmal genau interessieren. Aber es ist vielleicht auch eine andere Sendung. So, wir kommen zurück zum Glasfaser. Wir haben schon gerade drüber gesprochen, also schon sehr lange drüber gesprochen, dass wir im Prinzip Glasfaser wollen, weil schönes, schnelles Internet, aber das nicht geht, weil über Kupfer liegt. Und weder die Kleinen noch die großen Anbieter machen das. Und reguliert wird das auch nicht. Und wir haben noch einen Anrufer, den wir kurz reinnehmen wollen, den Frank. Der hat nämlich eine wilde Theorie, warum die Telekom vielleicht nicht Glasfaser ausbaut.
Hallo, also erst mal möchte ich sagen, also ich habe nichts gegen Glasfaser, nicht falsch verstehen. Ich bin trotzdem Telekom-Kunde, ich habe alle bei der Telekom. Ich habe auch IPTV über die Telekom. Also deshalb kann ich auch nicht zu irgendeinem anderen Anbieter wechseln. Und mich ärgert, wenn man so die News immer hört. Also ich hoffe und setze eigentlich auf VDSL2, dass ich das endlich mal bekomme. Aber dadurch, dass irgendwelche Kamminetzanbieter ständig irgendwelche Einsprüche einlegen, vor irgendwelche Gerichte ziehen, verzögert sich das alles. Und das finde ich genauso zum kotzen, als wenn man jetzt dieses Telekom-Monopol kritisiert. Das ist natürlich auch nicht in Ordnung. Da würde ich gerne mal eure Meinung hören.
Also, weil ich es richtig verstanden habe, soll VDSL2, was genau ist das?
VDSL2, der Nachfolger mit 100 MBit, jetzt im Augenblick noch im Downlink, also zum Kunden hin und 50 MBit vom Kunden, also 40 MBit in Richtung des Internets. VDSL2 wird, weil es sehr viel näher dieser dieser Schrank auf der Straße sehr viel näher an der Wohnung dranstehen muss, weil das Kabel wieder ein bisschen kürzer sein muss, um diese Bandbreite zu garantieren, wird das nicht bei allen gleich ausgebaut. Das zweite Problem ist, dass man Änderungen an den Schränken in der Straße durchführen muss und die es wird halt, da gibt es Ausbaupläne. Ich vermute im Internet gibt es eine Seite, da steht dann irgendwann drin, wann man es bekommen kann.
Aber was hat ihr jetzt von der Theorie sozusagen, dass der Ausbau mit breitbehaltener Internet dadurch sozusagen verhindert wird, dass die Telekom verklagt wird? Das habe ich nicht ganz genau verstanden. Also, weil das...
Na was verhindert wird, ist, dass die Telekom in den Kabelverzweigern, die da an der Straße stehen, die Technik so umbaut, dass die anderen ausgesperrt werden. Das ist das, was die Telekom im Prinzip da gerade aktiv tut. Mit mehr oder weniger technischen Gründen. Das hatten wir vorhin ja kurz gesagt. Wenn ich verschiedene Anbiete da drin habe, müssten die sich so synchronisieren, dass die Leitungen sich nicht gegenseitig stören, weil die Frequenzen die da übertragen werden, so hoch sind, dass das sonst sehr schnell passiert.
Also warte, ich will gucken, ob ich es verstanden habe. Die Telekom würde in die Kästen eine neue Technologie einbauen, um das Kupferinternet doch noch ein bisschen breitbandiger zu machen. Das würde dann aber dazu führen, dass sie sagen, ja, aber dann können wir keinen anderen mehr reinlassen, weil dann würden sie wieder stören.
Naja, nicht auf demselben Weg wieder rein. Sie dürfen sie ja nicht ganz aussperren, deswegen würden sie sie nicht ganz aussperren, sondern würden nur sagen, ihr dürft jetzt nicht euren eigenen Schrank daneben stellen, sondern ihr müsst jetzt von uns den Zugang zu gewissen Preisen einkaufen. Die sind halt deutlich höher als das, was die Mitbewerber jetzt zahlen.
Das heißt, im Prinzip bekommt dann andere Anbieter nur noch einen Tunnel über die Technik von der Telekom und hat auch selber keinen Einfluss mehr auf irgendwelche technischen Parameter, die da laufen.
Also quasi, die Abwägung, die gemacht wird, ist, entweder man lässt die Telekom gewähren, dann hätte man sozusagen einen Monopol, aber breitbändiges Internet oder man nimmt in Kauf, dass das verhindert wird, damit alle die Chance haben, da was zu machen.
Genau, dann müssen wir eben mal auf eine neue innovative Technik wieder das Glas setzen.
Okay, dann will ich den Frank kurz fragen, ob das deine Frage beantwortet.
Ja, dann hab ich noch kurz eine Frage. Also, was ich jetzt nicht verstehe ist, es werden doch bei den Telekom Kästen nur die DSL und VDSL-Anschlüsse denn monopolisiert. Glasfaser kann noch weiter, da braucht es doch nicht ein extra Kasten, die müssen einfach nur eine extra Leitung legen.
Ja, okay, also Frank, da würde ich aber tatsächlich bitten, lad dir nach der Sendung bitte den Podcast runter, weil genau dieses Thema, also was ist das Komplizierte am Glasfaseraufbau, das haben wir schon ganz ausführlich gesprochen.
In einem Satz das buddeln, das buddeln.
So sieht's aus. Und ich würde jetzt gerne sagen, zurückkommen zur, wie soll man sagen, zur Politik. Also gibt es vielleicht, also wir haben schon gehört, die Politik fordert irgendwie 100 MBit für alle oder in die 50 sogar nur. Also was sozusagen das ist, was wir eh schon haben. Gibt es vielleicht trotzdem irgendwo Pläne oder Visionen, dass wir irgendwie noch Glasfaser haben könnten?
Ja, man kann so ein bisschen in Berlin zumindest, kann man in den Koalitionsvertrag gucken und da feststellen, dass da verabredet ist, dass Glasfaser ausgebaut werden soll. Es wird aber nicht gesagt, wie, weil das ist aber natürlich logisch, weil in so einem Vertrag steht jetzt auch nicht jedes Detail drin. Sondern man will jetzt prüfen, wie man das in Berlin möglichst voranbringen könnte und möglicherweise mit landeseigenen Gesellschaften zusammenarbeiten könnte. Weil es gibt ja, Wasserbetriebe haben wir eben schon mal gehört, gibt ja Gesellschaften, die haben schon Infrastrukturen, die man vielleicht nutzen könnte, um weitere Kabel zu verlegen.
Ist es wirklich so das, was sich jetzt sozusagen dem Hirn anbietet? Nämlich die Wassergewerke haben einen Wasserrohr. Das heißt, ich hänge in das Wasserrohr einen Kabel rein?
So ungefähr war das ja bei der Berlikom, die ja ein Offspin sozusagen von einem Wasserbetrieb gewesen ist. Der Stefan weiß das alles im Detail noch ein bisschen genauer. Aber es war im Kern so, dass eine vorhandene Infrastruktur eben Abwasserkanäle und solches genutzt hat, um da drin einfach ohne zu buddeln, Kabel zu verlegen.
Aber das steht jetzt in einem Koalitionsantrag drin. Ich weiß, dass Sie jetzt ein bisschen Glaskugel lesen, aber hast du den Eindruck, das ist so was, da schreibt man da rein, weil es klingt gut und man muss sich auch nicht festlegen? Oder kann man da wirklich damit rechnen, dass so eine Art politischer Innovationsdruck entsteht?
Also ich glaube, einen Druck weiß ich nicht, aber es wird schon Initiativen geben. Es hat ja in der letzten Berliner Legislaturperiode ja auch schon so ein paar Initiativen gegeben mit diesem B-Digital und den Arbeitskreis Digitalisierung, den der Regine Bürgermeister initiiert hat, der aber seit dem Ende 2015 auch so ein bisschen schläft, glaube ich. Aber dadurch, dass das eben im Vertrag drin steht und speziell bei den Linken und bei den Grünen in den Wahlprogrammen schon drin stand, muss man jetzt mal gucken, wie in den Haushaltsberatungen, die jetzt anfangen für den Doppelhaushalt 2018, 2019, wie das da implementiert wird, dass hier so was geprüft werden soll. Also im Grunde genommen, so kleine Schritte. Das ist aber genau der Moment, wo wir haben ja am Anfang schon mal von Einmischen gesprochen, wo man sich theoretisch auch einmischen kann über Abgeordnete und andere Kanäle, um sich da einzubringen in so einen Diskussionsprozess, der gerade beginnt.
Okay. Wie ist es denn, wir haben Berlin vielleicht, Hamburg haben wir gehört, es gibt so ein paar Dinge. Es hat ein Hörer uns auch geschrieben, dass an der niederländischen Grenze anscheinend auch sozusagen eine Firma dabei ist, Dörfer einzusammeln und zu verglasfasern. Wie ist denn das eigentlich so, und der hat ja erklärt, woran das liegt, dass es nicht passiert. Das hängt vor allem mit Geldverdienen zusammen und dass es noch gut ohne Glasfaser geht. Wie ist denn das so im internationalen Vergleich? Sind wir da Breitbandvorreiter oder liegt in den anderen Ländern schon die Glasfaser?
Wenn du die Liste umdrehst, dann ja. Ich meine, stehen wir dieses Jahr auf der OECD-Liste überhaupt drauf.
Wie lange ist sie?
Ne, vorletzte glaube ich nach Litauen.
Wie lang ist sie?
Genau, es stehen 20 Länder auf dieser Liste drauf. Und wir sind auf Platz 18? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Verstehe. 26, Entschuldigung. Aber gibt es schon Länder, wo Glasfaser im Privatbereich sich wirklich durchgesetzt hat?
Sehr viele. Also Südkorea ganz massiv. In der Schweiz ist es sehr einfach. Bitte mal jetzt da noch rezitieren. Wir haben die Liste ja hier gerade vor uns. Also im Prinzip alle europäischen Länder sind da vor uns. Moment mal.
Also mal die Frau Cyprus zu zitieren, die ein Werbeflyer heute in die Zeit reingepackt hat. Global, innovativ und fair. Wir machen Zukunft digital. Da gibt es auf der Seite 4 eine Statistik. Platz 1 bis 26. 26 Deutschland mit 13, 7 Mbit. Durchschnittlicher Geschwindigkeit. Südkorea mit 26, 3. Hongkong, Norwegen, Schweden, Schweiz, Singapur, Japan, Finnland, Niederlande, Lettland. Das waren nur die ersten 10. Danach hat man sich dann gespart, die restlichen 15, die noch vor uns liegen, noch aufzuzählen.
Durchschnittliche Bandbreite.
Aber weiß man denn, wie die das gemacht haben? Warum zur Hölle noch mal liegt dort Glasfaser? Wie haben die das geschafft? Dieses Konglomerat aus großen Telekom-Firmen und fauler Politik. Ich meine, wir sind ja da nicht einzigartig in Deutschland.
Also in Südkorea zum Beispiel gab es eine große Initiative eines landesweiten Glasfaserausbaus, wo im Prinzip staatlich ein Großteil des Landes mit Glasfaser versorgt wurde.
Aber hat der Staat das selber gebaut? Oder der Staat hat die Firmen dazu verdonnert? Oder hat er gefördert? Also wie genau ist das passiert?
Man kann vermuten, dass das in Südkorea, das ist ein sehr spezieller Fall, weil man in Südkorea ja so ein paar ganz große Unternehmen hat, die fast staatsgleich schon sind, so Samsung und andere. Und da gibt es immer ein sehr enges Hand in Hand zwischen Regierung und Wirtschaft. Und insofern, wenn die das gemeinsam beschließen, wenn wir nötig befinden und das primär dann sicherlich erstmal auf den Großraum Soul sich fokussieren. Wenn man da mal gewesen ist, dann sieht man, wie da aber auch die Kabel verlegt werden. Das wird ein bisschen lockerer gehandhabt, auch bei uns. Oder auch in China. Dann kann man aber auch verstehen, warum das da viel viel schneller geht. Und die eine Penetration haben von 70 Prozent der Haushalte, die mit Glasfaser erreicht werden. Bei uns sind es 1, 2 oder irgendwas. Unabhängig von den Bandbreiten noch mal.
Nun darf man auch nicht vergessen, wenn wir uns zum Beispiel jetzt mal mit den USA vergleichen, dass der Vergleich hinkt noch mehr. Die stehen auch nicht viel besser da als wir. Aber dort ist es auch um Größenordnungen billiger, Haushalte anzuschließen, weil man es dort einfach an die Strommasten knüppert.
Aber um nochmal deine Frage aufzugreifen. Wir können ja mal ein Land nehmen, was nicht in Europa liegt. Und ich spiele jetzt nicht auf die Briten an, sondern auf die Schweiz. Die Schweiz hat es geschafft, die lokalen Platzführer, die Swisscom, dazu zu verdonnern in den großen Städten, den Glasfaserausbau voranzutreiben und anderen Providern den Zugang zu geben. Und das funktioniert dann so, dass die das Kabel halt in die Wohnung reinlegen. Und da gibt es einen Verteiler, so ein großes Metallgestell. Da kommen die ganzen Kabel, die ganzen Buchsen an, die zu den Wohnungen führen. Und man kann sich halt diese Glasfaser mieten und das zu einem fairen Preis, was dazu geführt hat, dass es auch jetzt Provider gibt, die sehr attraktive Gigabit-Angebote für Privatkunden anbieten, was wiederum natürlich auch den Platzführer dazu zwingt, neue Produkte anzubieten. Man nennt so was auch freien Wettbewerb.
Naja, aber trotzdem, wenn der eine Punkt sagt, die müssen das verlegen und dann wird ihnen vorgeschrieben, wie viel sie nehmen dürfen, oder haben die nur gesagt, also macht mal, aber wir gucken schon drauf, was sie da tut?
Die müssen die Faser Dritten zur Verfügung stellen. Das nennt man diskriminierungsfreien Zugriff.
Ja, aber dann können die ja immer noch die Preise festlegen. Also wie ist geregelt, dass die dann nicht sagen, hey, ihr könnt natürlich sozusagen 1000 Euro fürs... und so weiter.
Da das wahrscheinlich eine ganz stark politische Frage ist, kann man da natürlich, wenn man politisch aktiv ist, Einfluss draufnehmen. Und das scheint in der Schweiz geklappt zu haben. Und der Preis scheint so gut zu sein, dass es sich lohnt, in der Schweiz Glasfaseranschlüsse für Endkunden anzubieten.
Ja, was ist deine Lösung, sag mal?
Ja, endlich alle ideologischen Schranken über Wortwärts und eine komplette Verstaatlichung der Infrastruktur fordern. Also weg von dieser Kleinstatter reich.
Das ist doch Kommunismus! Nein, aber mal ehrlich, ich mein, mal abgesehen davon, dass Deutschland sozusagen sehr viel privatisiert hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten, ist das eine Idee, die auch sozusagen, also wo man sagt, okay, lieber Staat, deine Aufgabe ist, das Infrastruktur bereitzustellen?
Das machen wir doch, das heißt halt dann Telekom und die gehört dem Staat.
Ihr habt mir gerade fast zwei Stunden lang erklärt, dass die Telekom keine Glasfaser baut. So, jetzt nochmal die Frage, gibt es das als Idee oder politische Forderung irgendwie, dass man dem Staat dazu verdonnert, sozusagen, du musst das selber bauen?
Nein. Also nichts, das mir da bekannt ist, es mag vielleicht jetzt in bestimmten Landesparlamenten Ideen geben, aber auf Bundesebene habe ich davon noch gar nichts gehört.
Was würdet ihr davon halten?
Wäre das eine gute Idee? Es gibt diesen schönen Spruch, der Strom kommt aus der Steckdose und dann kommt das Internet auch aus der Steckdose. Und wir haben nachgewiesen, wir hatten Amerika gerade genannt mit dem maroden Stromnetz, wir haben nachgewiesen, dass eine Teilverstaatlichung von Infrastruktur keine so schlechte Idee ist. Und es gibt auch diese Ideen, dass man sagt, man trennt, wie bei der Deutschen Bahn, zum Beispiel das Streckennetz von dem, der nachher die Züge darauf rollen lässt. Und genau so ein Modell könnte in der Telekommunikation funktionieren. Aber da würde ich sagen, es gibt da immer noch unvor 20 Milliarden Euro, die die Telekom wert ist, Anteile von einer Telekom, die noch vom Staat gehalten wird über die KfW. Wenn man das so was verkaufen würde, das ist jetzt keine Idee, die ich hatte, das kann man nachlesen bei Heise, dann würde man dieses Geld natürlich wunderbar für so ein Initial, für so ein Start nutzen können, um so was zu realisieren. Ein Netz, was diskriminierungsfrei von allen Providern genutzt werden kann.
Vor allem das Schöne ist ja, dass man bei diesem Netz gar nicht alles auf einmal machen muss. Wir haben sehr, sehr viele Kommunen und sehr viele Stadtwerke, die lokal genau das versuchen. Also wie gesagt, das Beispiel von meinen Eltern zu Hause, die haben sechs Fasern in jede Wohneinheit und da können auch andere Anbieter sich diese Dark Fiber in die Wohnung kaufen und können dann da eigene Dienste drüber anbieten, unabhängig von diesen Stadtwerken, weil die erst mal nur die Infrastruktur hingelegt haben. Und man bekommt auch die Infrastruktur von denen, ohne bei denen einen Vertrag abzuschließen, dann bekommt man zwar keine Förderung, hat aber die Infrastruktur trotzdem da zum vernünftigen Preis.
Darf ich mal reingrätschen? Ja, da sind wir aber wieder bei enorm unnötigen Kosten und enorm verlangsamten Ausbau. Erklär mir mal, warum wir in Deutschland drei oder vier Handynetze brauchen. Wir haben drei oder vier miserable Handynetze. Das ist doch die Kermotte. Ich habe zum Beispiel das Spektrum, auch in der Luft, das ist ja das gleiche Thema wie zu Hause. Ich habe genau jedes Megahertz festgelegt. Ich kann nicht ausbrechen.
Aber Joseph, ich würde es gerne ein bisschen abkürzen. Seine Forderung ist generell kritische Infrastrukturen sollte man sozusagen verstehen.
In Frankreich, zum Beispiel mit der Kanalisation, war es genauso. Da hat man es privatisiert. Die Privaten haben ihr Geld rausgezogen, vergammeln lassen. In der Stadt muss es zurückkaufen, damit es zu keiner Umweltkatastrophe kommt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht zu sagen, ob Glasfaser auch vergammelt ist. Das dauert 100 Jahre. Also, Joseph, ich würde es an dieser Stelle kurz abbrechen wollen, weil ich möchte euch noch eine andere Frage stellen. Wenn in den Nachrichten von Breitbandausbau die Rede ist, dann wird die Industrie immer zitiert mit, ja, da muss der Staat fördern.
Er muss halt richtig fördern. Wenn ich einem großen Anbieter das Geld gebe für einen Breitbandausbau, der auf alte Technologie setzt, nämlich auf das Kupfer, dann bekomme ich halt keine Innovationen raus. Wenn ich jetzt das Geld nehme und Kommunen gebe, dann habe ich da sicherlich ein ganz anderes Ergebnis. Wenn die Kommunen nämlich dann anfangen können, ihre Industriegebiete und ihre Gewerbegebiete mit schnellem Internet zu versorgen, dann wandern da nämlich auch nicht die Firmen ab. Wenn ich ein Architekturbüro habe, das in einem Neubaugebiet sitzt, wo der Inhaber des Architekturbüros jeden Tag mit einem USB-Stick ins Internetcafé in die Stadt fahren muss, um seine Skizzen loszuwerden, das ist Realität.
Ja, aber warte, es gibt Fördertöpfe und die sollen sozusagen den Kommunen gegeben werden. Und die sollen die dann frei entscheiden können. Also quasi entweder wir verlegen die Kabel selber oder wir beauftragen jemanden, der das macht. Also meinetwegen auch einen großen Telekom-Anbieter kann man ja sagen. Kann hingehen und sagen, pass auf Telekom-Anbieter, die Frage ist nicht, ob wir das machen oder nicht, sondern die Frage ist, willst du das machen oder nicht?
Na, wenn dafür gesorgt ist, dass mit diesem öffentlichen Geld danach ein diskriminierungsfreies Netz da ist, was eben nicht wieder das Monopolselementiert, weil dazu hohe Preise von den Mitbewerbern verlangt werden.
Ich wäre absolut im Augenblick dagegen, irgendwelche Fördergelder rauszugeben. Ich würde die gesamte Förderung einstellen. Warum? Der Hintergrund dabei ist, dass einfach zu wenig kontrolliert wird, was rauskommt. Es wird zu wenig zweckgebunden gefördert. Man fördert den Ausbau des Breitbandes in Bayern. Jetzt versucht man in München als kleine Firma einen Glasfaseranschluss zu kriegen. Man ist ein innovatives Start-up-Unternehmen, man kriegt es nicht. Aber wie der Bitkom-Präsident gerade gesagt hat, die deutschen Bauernhöfe haben mehr digitale Technik im Einsatz als der Mittelstand in Deutschland. Woran liegt das?
Die müssen aber auch ihre Traktoren hacken, habe ich neulich gelesen.
Sie haben aber auch Drohnen im Einsatz und jede Kuh hat einen Chip im Ohr. Es ist einfach so, dass es dann ganz große Schere gibt. Solange Gelder einfach mit der Gießkanne vergeben, ausgestreut werden, und so ist der Eindruck, der bei mir einfach hängen bleibt, wenn ich die Werbepamplete zum Thema Breitbandausbau lese und das nicht zweckgebunden ist und auch nicht mal berücksichtigt wird, dass die Demoskopie sagt, dass über 90 Prozent der deutschen Bevölkerung in großstädtischen Ballungsräumen lebt und dafür anscheinend kein Konzept ist, außer dass man da vorgaukelt, dass es dort einen freien Wettbewerb gibt, dann sollen sie einen freien Wettbewerb schaffen und dann sollten sie vielleicht das eine Unternehmen, was teilweise in staatlicher Hand ist, vielleicht überlegen, was sie damit machen, versilbern und das Geld für Für sinnvolle Zwecke einsetzen, zweckgebunden.
Vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung dazu. Fördern heißt auch nicht notwendigerweise, dass Geld vergeben wird, weil beispielsweise die Telekom keine Fördergelder in der Regel braucht, aber natürlich Investitionen nur dann tätigt, wenn sie einen gewissen Bestandsschutz auch bekommt, über lockere Regulierungsvorgaben. Also das ist ja ein ganz wesentlicher Teil. Gerade bei diesem Vectoring war das ja ein ganz wesentlicher Diskussionspunkt. Immer ein wichtiges Argument der Telekom, die gesagt hat, wir wollen X Milliarden investieren, aber dann wollen wir von euch auch die Garantie haben, dass wir das Geld auch zurückverdienen können und nicht dazu gezwungen werden, alle anderen in unsere Netze reinzulassen. Also das ist eine Art der Förderung.
Aber das ist ja quasi das Gegenteil von dem, was gerade hier in breiter Runde gefordert wird. Weil das diskriminierungsfrei ist, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, genau dieses Reinlassen ins Netz.
Ja, das ist richtig. Das ist das, was dann auf der Netzebene passiert. Aber vorher im politischen Raum, wo eben über sowas verhandelt wird und zwar tagtäglich, läuft das eben auf so einer Ebene ab.
Also ich sehe ja ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen schwarz für meinen Gigabit-Anschluss. Bei mir zu Hause, ich würde jetzt gerne noch eine sozusagen kurze Abschlussrunde machen. Und ihr könnt entweder sozusagen mir sagen, was ich jetzt tun kann, damit ich vielleicht doch meinen Gigabit kriege. Oder mir eine realistische Einschätzung geben, wie lange das in Deutschland noch dauern wird. Bis es sozusagen, bis es nicht mehr die Ausnahme ist, dass es sowas gibt.
Das einfachste ist, du ziehst um in ein Land, wo es das gibt. Das gibt wahrscheinlich auch am schnellsten. Ich hab gehört, die Schweiz ist sehr schön. Ansonsten wahrscheinlich wirklich politisch aktiv werden, Druck aufbauen und Informationen weitergeben, wie immer leider. Wir haben in Deutschland leider einen sehr, sehr, sehr starken Robiismus in dem Bereich.
Nochmal das Worst-Case-Szenario. Okay, wir haben das Vectoring, wir haben das VDSL2. Aber trotzdem werden wir irgendwann an den Punkt kommen, wo das dann nicht mehr reicht. Was ist das Worst-Case-Szenario, wann wir mit Glasfaserausbau anfangen, weil es nicht mehr anders geht?
60 Monate.
60, what is it, sir?
Abschreibungszeit des Equipments, was jetzt verbaut wird.
Naja, aber es ist ja so, ich habe damals, als die 3D-Fernseher zum ersten Mal vorgeführt wurden, dann habe ich gesagt, wann kommt die denn? Dieses Jahr oder nächstes Jahr? So, nee, die werden erst mal die ganzen HD-Fernseher sozusagen den Markt voll machen. Erst wenn die dann HD-Fernseher hat, dann werden die 3D-Fernseher kommen. Analog, klar, also nach dem jetzt hingeklickt, dann könnten sie Glasfaser bauen. Aber es gibt vielleicht noch Zwischenstufen, was sie...
Herr DVB-T haben sie jetzt auch ausgemacht, nachdem das abgeschrieben war.
Also in 60 Monaten kriegen wir dann Glasfaser.
Der andere Tipp ist einfach mal zu gucken, wo Fördergelder fließen und sich vielleicht mal so ein kleines Dorf aussuchen, was jetzt ein Glasfaserausbau bekommt.
Ich möchte nicht umziehen, herrgott. Kann auch nicht so schwer sein.
Das ist schöner, da gibt es Kühe.
Und Bauernhöfe.
Allerletzte Frage, die ich an euch habe ist, und da gehen wir nochmal an Anfang zurück. Ihr habt ja gesagt, sind Symmetrisches ganz richtig. Gigabit will ich nicht nur als Download haben, sondern auch als Upload. Jetzt hast du gesagt, man kann seinen eigenen Fileserver betreiben, also quasi die Fotos nicht mehr zu Flickr oder sonst wo hochladen, sondern halt am eigenen Rechner. Aber habt ihr noch so andere Beispiele, was da noch möglich wäre, wenn wir alle breitbandiges, symmetrisches Internet zu Hause hätten?
Nehmen wir einfach mal so eine Großfamilie. Man hat drei Generationen und man kommt von einem Familienurlaub zurück und will all seinen Lieben eigentlich zeigen, was man da gemacht hat. Dann müsste man heute, damit alle das sehen können, entweder mit den USB-Sticks rumfahren oder ein paar Posts verschicken oder man müsste die Dinge in die Cloud laden oder an irgendwelche anderen Firmen drauf Zugriff haben, könnten und die dann wiederum für was auch immer das nutzen. Wir hatten es ja zweimal in den Nachrichten, was man damit machen kann. Wenn man jetzt so einen Breitbandanschluss hätte, dann könnte man auch bei der Oma so eine kleine Kiste hinstellen, mit einer Festplatte drin oder auch ohne und die könnten direkt zugreifen auf die Daten. Das heißt, man könnte seine eigene Familien-Cloud aufbauen, in dem Augenblick, wo man mehr Bandbreite auch ins Netz hat.
Aber das hat der Verhinten nicht mal so weit gehen.
Was gibt es denn noch?
Wir haben diese ganzen VR-Brillen-Geschichten. Es gibt aktuell halt keine Technik, die das benutzt, weil wir haben keine Bandbreite. Wer spricht denn dagegen, dass ich eine 3D-Kamera bei mir zu Hause habe und damit ein Familientreffen mit so einer VR-Brille mache? Und dann können halt Leute, die sonst wo sitzen, das Gefühl bekommen, dass sie bei mir im Wohnzimmer sitzen und sich mit mir unterhalten. Diese Anwendung würde momentan gar nicht funktionieren, weil ich diese Datenmengen gar nicht zu den anderen Leuten bekommen aus meinem Wohnzimmer.
Na gut, wir haben also heute gelernt, wir wollen mehr Internet, aber wir werden es nicht bekommen. Ich beschließe die Sendung damit. Bedanke und verabschiede mich herzlich von Johannes, Stefan, Filz und Mutags. Tschüssi. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.